à thông cảm. Bây giờ mình vừa mới vừa
mới cài lại môi trường trên máy này. Nếu
các bạn để ý thì đây sẽ là mánh m không
còn là Windows nữa nên là ừ mình vừa
phải cài lại các thứ xong. Thực ra là
camera thì đang dùng camera của Ma đấy.
Không phải camera cũ. Mic thì vẫn là mic
cũ.
Nhưng mà đấy, đây cũng là sẽ sự trở lại
khi mà mình cũng có thay đổi đó là chúng
ta bây giờ chúng ta sẽ học Java. Ờ đầu
tiên cái ảnh thăm thì mình vừa rồi mình
vừa dùng Germany để mà tạo ra cái ảnh
thăm nhưng mà ảnh đấy nó to ấy, nó kích
cỡ 7 m à. Xong mình thử tăng lên thì
không được bả chỉ được hai m thôi. Mình
bảo sửa lại thì Germany có vẻ cá nhân
mình đến thời điểm hiện tại mình dùng
dùng Gemini mình vẫn rất khó chịu. Không
biết là mấy có chuyên gia prom nào ở đây
không để mà nói việc là kiểu dùng mini
tốt hơn. Cá nhân thì mình thì mình thích
a trò chuyện hay nói chuyện với chatt
khá là nhiều tốt hơn.
À đây nói chuyện nhá. Còn code thì đương
nhiên chúng ta bây giờ hàng đầu vẫn là
cloud đúng không ạ? Thực ra tôi cũng
không biết phát âm mấy từ đấy lắm nên là
từ tiếng Anh có gì bỏ qua nhá.
Anh học Java có lên Spring không? Ờ thực
ra mình có nghe nói Spring này như là
framework của
framework của Java. Và ừ mình sẽ đầu
tiên mình nói qua mục tiêu của cái khóa
học này đã nhá. Thì mục tiêu khóa học
này đó là
như các bạn đã biết thì mình xuất phát ở
từ PP đúng không ạ? Thực ra mình có học
Java hồi học ở trường rồi nhưng mà
trường đấy là kiểu trường nghề ấy thì nó
sẽ học kiểu khá là kiểu chỉ à thiên về
thực hành hơn là lý thuyết là một việc
là bởi vì là bọn bọn mình hồi đấy là có
vững PP rồi nghĩa là làm xong đồ án một
rồi xong ngồi mới học sang Java thì
thường là bọn mình sẽ kiểu được lựa chọn
ngôn ngữ để mà học ấy. Tức là học Java
chỉ qua môn thôi chứ không chú trọng
việc là phải học chuyên sâu và Java. Thế
nên là hồi đấy mình nhớ học tận hai môn
Java nhá. Java cơ bản và Java gọi là OOP
đấy. Nhưng mình chỉ nhớ mang máng các
thứ thôi. Nhưng mình có biết một điều đó
là Java rất là xịn này, rất chặt chẽ các
thứ thứ. Tuy là tôi là gọi là
em là fan của PP 10 năm rồi đấy. Nhưng
mà vẫn phải công nhận là
Java có những cái mà PP hiện có vẻ vẫn
đang chưa có. Cho dù PP thay đổi rất là
nhiều nhá. từ PP hồi mình dùng là từ PP5
cho đến PP8 là bây giờ thay đổi rất rất
nhiều rồi. Cũng chặt chẽ hơn rồi, cũng
nhanh hơn rồi. Xong rồi cái gì Java có
thì PP cũng một là kiểu có thư viện hay
các thứ hỗ trợ vân vân nhưng mà để mà
nói là kiểu xịn hẳn vàng cả là bây giờ
chỉ đơn giản là ờ các công ty tuyển đúng
không? Đấy, kiểu thế thì rõ ràng là mình
không nên theo. Theo mình từ trước nay
thì đó là lập trình viên mình không nên
kiểu dập khuôn, mình suy nghĩ là kiểu
mình bắt buộc là mình phải
chỉ cố định một cái gì đó. Đấy,
tại sao lại Java không phải là CSAP hay
ngôn ngữ khác? Bởi vì đấy đấy là ấn
tượng của mình. Mình nhớ là Java thứ
nhất là về mình muốn show về back end là
về
OOP.
Chính xác là thực ra mình chỉ quan tâm
về việc được làm các bài toán chuyên sâu
kiểu nghiệp vụ với kiểu bài toán lớn ấy,
hệ thống lớn ấy thì thường là nó sẽ là
nghe nói sẽ là Java nhiều đấy. Và sau
Java chưa chắc là mình sẽ chỉ dừng ở
Java. Mình định là nhiều người vẫn
khuyên mình là từ PP để nhảy sang Go thì
tốt hơn đấy. Nhưng mà mình muốn học Java
để code để nắm chặt về hướng đối tượng
thì nghe nói là Java là cái gọi là best
practice à tức là kiểu cái phù hợp nhất
để học về hướng đối tượng là cả design
button này các thứ nó chặt chẽ nó ổn
đấy. Xong rồi về à
nhăng hôm qua mình có ngồi nói chuyện
với ông em ông em cũng dạy mình về Java
đây. Đây là cái repo của ông em tạo cho
mình đây. Thì
không em cũng anh lúc đấy mình cũng có
chia sẻ là mình làm PP mình chỉ biết mỗi
về mảng thôi, VR thôi, Java có thêm
những cái nữa đây đến lúc khám phá rồi.
Kiểu kiểu thế nói chung là đến lúc mình
học sau đó nữa thì như vừa nãy bạn này
có hỏi là mình có lên spring không thì
nếu mà nó là framework đầu tiên mình vẫn
hướng là Java cơ bản nhá mình sẽ đi từ
đúng kiểu cơ bản như chưa biết gì nhưng
mà mình sẽ tua nhanh nếu mà giả sử kiểu
có vài cái là kiểu
ví dụ vài cái cú pháp cơ bản thì có thể
biết rồi thì mình sẽ có thể tô nhanh gì
đó các bạn sẽ thấy là một kêu là 100
ngày nhưng mà có thể là nó sẽ không có
thể sẽ nhanh có thể có thể thôi nhá trừ
khi mình học kém không biết được nhưng
mà mình vẫn sẽ muốn là học kiểu kiểu là
có MVC này có framework này đấy
và mục tiêu của cái a buổi mục tiêu của
cái playlist này của những cái a a gọi
là khóa này thì mình muốn là thứ nhất là
đồng hành cùng các bạn để mà các bạn sẽ
hỗ trợ mình nếu có thể và mình sẽ cùng
học. Biết đâu là có ông sinh viên nào đó
cũng của tôi cũng từng kiểu học của tôi
PP và bây giờ chỉ biết mỗi PP thôi. Giờ
đến lúc rồi đúng không ạ?
Uầy các bạn hôm nay đông bình luận đúng
kiểu tôi tôi nhớ tôi nhớ có rất nhiều
ông đã từng gài tôi là là
kiểu học Java đi anh các thứ thứ chắc
chắn mấy ông ấy sẽ vào đây chiều tối đây
đợi tí thầy bật cam rồi sao à thì gần
đây cũng có bật mà kiểu thế này tương
tác cho mọi người thựt ra là tôi hôm nay
tôi cân nhắc ấy bởi vì rõ ràng là hồi
trước tôi dậy là tôi chỉ muốn mấy ông
tập trung vào màn hình để dậy thôi nhưng
mà thôi thì mở ở cam để cho mấy ông cảm
thấy là ừ đang nói chuyện về người
Java thực ra là tôi có cái GitHub ở đây
thực ra cũng công khai này để mấy ông có
thể ngồi mò nó cũng chả có gì cả thôi
dùng chính AI để mà ngồi soạn ra soạn ra
lộ trình học như thế này đấy thì à mấy
ông có thể vào tham khảo hoặc thậm chí
là góp ý là kiểu không nên học như này
vân vân vân thế nào cũng được. Ờ hôm qua
thì tôi mới chạy chạy thử. Nghĩa là thực
tế là hôm nay là buổi thứ hai nhá, không
phải buổi đầu đâu. Tôi kêu thế thôi.
Nhưng mà hôm qua đã thử mỏ thử rồi xôi.
Thầy hay quá nên thành ra kéo mới quyết
là quay lại livestream để mà học. Bởi vì
tôi hứa hẹn với mấy anh em là tôi sẽ thử
học cùng anh em. Cái này từ lâu rồi, từ
lâu lắm rồi.
ạ. Không phải cuso ạ. À đây để mình so
sánh về code. Mình mình chưa dùng clou
code nhá. Thì mình chỉ biết được là đây
mình nói theo cái trải nghiệm cá nhân
của mình từ đầu nhá. Thì hồi trước là
nếu mấy ông có biết là hồi trước tôi
dùng PP Storm này. Đấy. Đấy. Sau về sau
có khải nghiệm là trên này có cái
plugin.
Tôi nói lịch sử từ đầu luôn là
plugin là tim. Ui, hồi đấy kiểu gợi ý ra
hết một dòng đã sướng lắm rồi. Đấy, xong
rồi về sau là có
à Git Hub Cilot đấy.
Cilot đấy. Xong rồi về sau là ờ dần dần
là tôi cũng mất cái
mất cái trả phí của PP Storm và tôi cảm
thấy là thực ra không cần ham hố IDE nữa
mà chuyển qua dùng VS Code cũng được.
Thì vào đấy tôi dùng VS code đương nhiên
là cũng có GitHub nhá. Copilot GitHub
nhưng về sau thấy có một thằng nữa cũng
khá là ngon và miễn phí. Copot đuy nhiên
là mất phí trừ khi ông có meod đúng
không ạ? Nó là
code IUM
là miễn phí. Đấy
xong rồi à
sau đó thì code IUM đầu tiên code EUM
hình như là bán hay đổi tên gì đấy đại
khái thì bằng Win search.
Đây như này. Xong rồi. Tôi đã từng dùng
qua cái argument argument code đâu? Tôi
không nhớ tên tôi phải tra thông cảm anh
em thông cảm. Đợ tí aument tôi dùng
thằng này đúng một lần hồi mà nó kiểu
lúc mới lúc mới tải về nó cho bàn thông
thử đúng không ạ? Tôi làm cái app tính
tính điểm chơi tá lả [tiếng cười]
xong ngồi nó ngồi chạy vòng lặp cả hai
ngày hôm đấy tôi cứ ngồi xem nó chạy
vòng lập để ngồi tính tính tính các
trường hợp ôi chán xóa đấy đại khái thì
con đấy chuyên về giá lệnh nhiều hơn ấy
không phải với code lắm đấy với góc nhìn
của tôi nhá tôi vẫn đang chia sẻ góc
nhìn bản thân thôi đấy
đâu cái này phải bằng đổi Ok. Sau đó thì
tôi chuyển qua dùng Winser. Bởi vì nghe
nói là nó mới ra thằng res này hồi đấy
nó bảo là
bằng cuso
cộng với agent gì gì nó của nó là cái gì
đó ấy. Đấy không phải Cassandra đâu. Tôi
quên mất tên nó rồi
đấy. Tôi chưa dùng COR cho dù công ty
tôi có mua cho mua tài khoản cho anh em
dùng CO nhưng mà à không tôi có dùng COR
chứ gần đây tôi có tải rồi có dùng rồi
tôi mới nhận ra là đúng
là tôi sẽ là thằng này cũng có khá xịn
các thứ thứ thậm chí là tôi thấy có cái
vụ mấy ông không biết là có cái vụ đúng
là Cassade đấy đúng rồi đúng nhá đấy
cái app ở trên điện thoại à như thờ ra
đấy nhúng app nhúng thôi xong rồi tôi
còn kiểu cho nó quyền thì nó gọi lên kit
hub repo của mình để kiểu đẩy code các
thứ thứ cơ rất mù mè các thứ thứ nhưng
xong rồi tôi vẫn phải quay lại thằng Vin
search bởi vì sao bởi vì nếu mà anh em
code thì anh em sẽ biết được là mấy
thằng à đa số bây giờ mấy thằng ấy thì
mình ra lệnh nó qua mấy cái model ở đây.
Đương nhiên là chúng ta vẫn dùng thằng
cloude code này là cloue cái cái agent
cloude này vẫn là đang xịn về code đúng
không?
Thì
thì mấy thằng này nó kiểu tự động làm
cho mình và nó sẽ có nếu mà thằng cúo ấy
nó sẽ không hiển thị ra tường minh là
thằng model thằng agent đang nghĩ gì đấy
nên thành ra là ông chỉ biết kiểu ra
lệnh xôi đợi nó kết quả thôi ông sẽ kiểu
không xác nhận lại được không kiểu tôi
thỉnh thoảng bây giờ tôi phải dùng mấy
cái từ tiếng Anh chuyên ngành Tí mấy ông
thông cảm nhá. Là phải confirm lại cái
plan của nó đúng không? Đấy. Đấy nên
thành ra là thường là tôi vẫn từ thời
tôi dùng search không biết mấy ông có
dùng AI giống như tôi dùng không là tôi
luôn bắt nó ghi ra một cái file ma down
để mà kiểu mà cái to delete ý kiểu để
biết được là à bạn cần phải làm những
cái gì vân vân vân vân. Đấy. Đấy. Xong
rồi. À thì thằng CON này nó không hiển
thị ra cái tường minh là cái luồng agent
đang làm gì, đang nghĩ gì nên thành ra
tôi phải quay lại search. Nhưng mà
search tôi thấy tốn cũng 1 tháng là tôi
cũng phải kiểu review lại cái credit của
nó.
gì cơ nhá. Thôi tôi sẽ không
gì nhỉ?
Sau đó thì đến bây giờ các bạn đang thấy
thì tôi dùng antigravity
đúng như bạn kia vừa nói đúng
antigravity chính là winsert bởi vì đã
từng có quả lộ là tôi nhớ là quả lộ là
nó trong một cái gì đó của nó hiển thị
ra cá cassan cade này này của nó đấy.
Nạp credit thì nó vẫn không đúng refw
tức là đầy lại mà đúng không? Đấy không
biết từ như nào đấy
xong rồi à đại khái thì antiravity này
có cái hay là nó winser cộng với một cái
nữa nó là planning
này này chính là cái mà vừa nãy tôi có
đề cập là tôi thường hay bắt thằng thằng
mấy thằng này viết ra cái file ma để mà
kiểu lên cái danh sách các thứ vân vân
vân vân đúng không ạ thì thằng
antigravity này nó mặc định là cái đấy
là điều hiển nhiên rồi khi mà chuyển chế
độ blending này đấy. này
và đúng thằng An Gra tôi tôi không có
mồi chào mấy ông nạp tiền để mà mua đồ
công nghệ bây giờ nhá bởi vì rõ ràng th
anti garanti hiện tại đang miễn phí thì
cũng hay là một đúng không ạ thứ hai đó
là
à hồi trước là tôi từng bỏ tiền ra để
mua chatt
một tháng cũng 20 đô đấy để mà ngồi tâm
sự tuổi hồng cả hồi đấy còn nhiều nó cốt
nhưng bây giờ à u ôi bây giờ tôi cảm
Thấy ạ. Cloud code ngon nhất này. Đây
tôi vứt này xuống đây. Đấy với tôi nhá.
Thì đó là trên mini này hiện tại. Xong
rồi mới đến qu này thực ra chưa dùng.
Xong rồi mới đến a chatvt codex. Đấy tức
là chat TV giờ code rất tệ. Đấy tôi thà
dùng Gemini xong rồi cloue hơn. Đây nó
cũng có này cái GBT này như là cũng của
Codex thì phải không biết được. Nhưng
đại khái là tôi toàn dùng mấy cái này.
Đấy.
đại khái thế. Nghĩa là bây giờ tôi không
nạp tiền chatt nữa. Tôi dùng cái tiền
đấy để mà mua antiravity bằng giá mà. Mà
trong khi đó là nó được hiện tại thì tôi
đang được gọi là hỗ trợ giá là 3 tháng
đầu được 50.000. Đấy. Tùy tầng tùy từng
tài khoản Google của các bạn nhá. Nhưng
mà đại khái thì nó có mình có Gemini để
mà mình chat. Nhưng mà Gemini lúc đầu
video tôi nói đây nó rất là vẫn rất là
tệ. Tôi vẫn nói chuyện tâm sự với CHVT
thôi. Nhưng mà có anti Gravity này cái
này ngon ở điểm là đang dùng model này
thoải mái. Tôi không biết là kiểu khoe
mấy ông xong nó có limit của tôi đi
không như bởi vì kiểu sợ kiểu spam
server nó quá. Nhưng mà bình thường ông
dùng antigravity thì tầm một tuần thì nó
sẽ reset cái độ limit.
Còn à nếu mà ông bản mất phí như thế này
thì sẽ là tầm 4 tiếng rồi phải. 4 tiếng
thì reset rồi. Nên là tôi tôi rất hiếm.
Cũng có một lần chạm được đến limit rồi.
Nhưng mà limit là limit của Clode thôi.
Còn chuyển qua à Gemini dùng vẫn bình
thường nhá.
Ui, nãy giờ có anh em bình luận nhiều
quá. Đợi tí tôi trả lời bình luận đã.
nhất phải không phải cồ bởi vì đấy nếu
mà ông vừa theo một cái thang đo này của
tôi đúng không? Đấy, thì ông sẽ thấy là
tôi đang thích nhất thằng Antigravity.
Đấy, cho dù là thằng antiravity này,
Winsert này, hay cusal thì nó đều là tôi
thấy là đều là lõi VS code cả.
ông đặt tên như này được ra tôi không
nhớ không nhớ được ai với ai. Trừ khi
mấy ông bình luận à kiểu nhắn tin
Messenger thôi.
Có lưu lại video stream không? Có bạn có
gì bạn có thể xem lại vì mình thấy đa số
người xem của mình thường hay xem lại
kiểu giờ mình live lờ giờ mọi người ăn
này, giờ mọi người đang đi chơi với gấu
này vân vân vân.
Hôm trước mới có người khoe với tôi là
là
mở của tôi nghe giống như kiểu podcast
để mà ngồi làm việc á. Ui, tôi cảm thấy
kiểu phục vãi kiểu bởi vì từ trước đến
nay thì tôi luôn nghĩ là tôi tâm sự hay
nói chuyện mấy ông thì một là mấy ông
nghe được ngay tại thời điểm đấy để cho
vui, để giết thời gian gì đó, hai là để
mở lên để nghe du ngủ
bởi vì giọng cứ đều đều ấy. Lần đầu tiên
có người bảo tôi là nghe nghe anh nói
chuyện podcast để em ngồi làm việc đấy.
J2. Ui, xin chào bạn. Các bạn vẫn còn ở
đây tôi cũng ngạc nhiên lắm rồi. Nhưng
mà tôi nghĩ là video của tôi cũng sẽ
người cũ xem và nhiều thôi chứ tôi cũng
có quảng bá các thứ đâu. Cũng ít khi có
người mới lắm.
Thầy dạy Javacore hay sâu hơn ạ? Không,
tôi có dạy gì đâu. Tôi đi học mà. Đây là
buổi đầu học luôn ấy. Tí là tôi sẽ nhờ
anh em ở đây kiểu chỉ dẫn và ngồi học
cùng thôi.
là bây giờ tôi không còn dậy nữa. Tôi
chỉ dạy à à cũng không biết được xong
này người ta có mời về dạy tiếp không.
Đại khái thì năm ngoái thì thì họ nhờ
dạy môn tin học lớp 12 bởi vì tin lớp 12
bây giờ thì sẽ có kiến thức của năm nhất
năm nhất đại học. Thế là tôi dạy được
thì tôi mới nhận dạy.
software Engineer lúc nào không hay. Uây
thế quá vip luôn. Hi vọng các bạn trụ
được cái nghề này. Bởi vì bây giờ cạnh
tranh này xong rồi tỉ lệ
mọi thứ nó cũng nhiều đúng không ạ? Ơ
đợi tí đợi tí
tôi chạm vào màn hình.
Có bị sao? S
cái
kiểu m nền đằng sau thôi chứ mình không
rõ là có đang có filter gì không.
Review tai nghe á. Cái nghe này thực ra
là mình mua là ủng hộ lúc mà cái
cửa hàng đấy
thanh lý nốt cho cửa hàng đấy, cửa hàng
ấy đóng ấy. Và cái tai nghe này mục đích
duy nhất của mình đó là ừ thì mình mất
hồi trước mình bị mất cái tai nghe có
dây rồi nên bây giờ mình mua và code là
bây giờ từ toàn để cắm cái mic này nên
là mình cũng chưa nghe nhạc gì cả nên
khó đánh giá.
Trước em học PP Lare từ Anh và giờ công
ty đang định hướng chuyển sang Java
luôn. Uầy quá phù hợp luôn bạn ơi. Kiểu
thực ra là mình học à mình rõ ràng hồi
trước mình chỉ chuyên về backend nhưng
gần đây công ty bắt đầu điều hướng cho
mình sang full stack. Hồi trước vẫn là
full stack về làm JavaScript rồi nhưng
mà không biết gì CS cả. Đấy thì công ty
đang điều hướng mình sang full stack là
vừa động vào một tí CS nhá và vừa phải
đang từ view thì nhảy sang cả react nữa.
Nhưng mà cảm ơn may bây giờ có ai uâ
trên mini để ngồi làm giao diện đẹp kinh
khủng kiểu xong rồi à đúng rồi thằng
antiravity này nó vẫn bị cái điểm chung
của hàng Google đó là nó kết nối thất
bại. Nó không thể báo cho mình là kết
nối thất bại. Tức là sao? Nghĩa là hồi
trước mình dùng Win search xong mình
dùng cái MCB này để kết nối với Figma để
mà kiểu BA bên mình vẽ giao diện trên
Figma rồi. Ấ thì con model này theo lý
thuyết là nó sẽ kết nối đến cái Figma
đấy để đọc được cái giao diện xong rồi
làm giao diện làm ra trong web giao diện
đẹp hoành tráng. Ok. Đấy hồi trước mình
dùng resarch làm được ngon lành. So con
này lần đấy là key nó bị lỗi hay gì đó
khái thế nó tự bịa giao diện nhưng nó
không h mình biết được kết nối bị lỗi
đấy thành ra là mấy lần liền mình thấy
kiểm tra lại hóa ra là nó không kết nối
được đấy đấy là nhược điểm của hàng
Google hiện tạ đó là Google cạnh tranh
kiểu cố tung ra rất nhiều thằng bây giờ
để cạnh tranh với những cái thằng hiện
tạ bởi vì rõ ràng ông đấy ông to mà bây
giờ để đi sau về công nghệ là không được
đúng không ạ nhưng Mà nó rất cấn ở điểm
là nó không nhận nó sai. Thằng Gemini
thế
mấy lần tôi thấy phải hỏi đi hỏi lại nó
xác nhận rất mệt.
Thầy thử xài Intel Ligi thay vì VS Code.
Ờ thực ra là hôm qua tôi cũng có nghe
ông bảo là cài mấy cái ID kiểu có sẵn
các s thứ rồi tự nhiên kiểu đây hơi kiểu
khổ ấy. Nhưng mà mình muốn học từ đầu
thì thậm chí là bây giờ bảo mình học nốt
pad mình cũng được. Chẳng qua cái cái
thằng này có thêm AI mình thích thôi
kiểu gõ nó tiện thôi chứ mình không muốn
là kiểu đấy ví dụ hôm qua ông kia lạm
dụng EE đấy đúng không? Tôi bảo ông đấy
thử gõ lệnh ra ông không quên mất câu
lệnh gõ luôn. Nghĩa là chỉ là bị phụ
thuộc quá quên mất câu lệnh các thứ thứ.
Đấy.
antigravity đấy. Ai rồi cũng sẽ trở
thành phiên bản mình từng ghét rồi. Anh
anh live liên tục 100 ngày à anh? Lúc
đầu tôi định thế nhưng mà sẽ có rất
nhiều hôm kiểu phướng lịch hay gì đó
kiểu ví dụ là tuần sau tuần sau này là
công ty tôi
à tiệc cuối năm này tôi còn lên nhảy nữa
thì tôi không tôi không nghĩ là tôi thể
livestream vào hôm đấy đấy
vẫn bảo là Cloude CLD xong rồi cloue cod
COD à không biết hai cái đây có là một
không nhưng mà mình chưa dùng cái đấy.
Một phần này hình như cái đấy phải nạp
tiền đ vậy. Nói chung là tôi nghĩ là tôi
vẫn sẽ định thử sau.
Java G bố ra Java không không 100 ngày
chỉ làm một cái cơ bản thôi. Nhưng mà
đúng là bây giờ mình phải thích nghi dần
đấy.
Con antigravity thỉnh thoảng nó bị limit
giới hạn ấy. Nó giống kiểu chattivity
miễn phí là kiểu
ông nếu mà ông dùng vào trong lúc mà
kiểu đang đông người dùng ấy có thể nó
sẽ đơ thì phải. Cái cái việc họ trả lời
câu hỏi này này. Và thứ hai thì tôi thấy
là cái tốc độ gợi ý của nó có vẻ chậm
hơn so những thằng khác. Sếp tôi cũng
kiến nghị việc đấy. À đúng rồi, thằng
antiravity này một trong những cái mà
tôi cảm thấy là nó vẫn gọi là
à rẻ hơn so thằng khác nhá. Cho dù rõ
ràng 20 đô đúng không? Đó là ông dùng
được cho cả family của ông.
Nghĩa là bây giờ Google Family của tôi
đang có năm người phải năm hay sáu người
gì đấy. Đấy cả family dùng được. Tính ra
bây giờ ông mời cả anh em trong công ty
ông giả sử 500.000N đi xong rồi năm
người mỗi người 100 mà dùng tài khoản
này độc lập không bị limit theo tài
khoản độc lập với tài khoản kia dùng bét
nhè
không biết sao nữa tôi thấy không quan
trọng AI nào nữa. Miễn đặt câu hỏi rõ
ràng thì AI nào cũng giống nhau.
Ừ
hồi trước tôi cũng nghĩ thế. Hồi trước
là tôi không để ý mấy cái vụ này. Tôi
gần đây tôi bắt đầu tìm hiểu ấy, kiểu
gần đây tôi ép tôi phải tìm hiểu. Bởi vì
thực sự là nó khác biệt quá lớn nên là
tôi mới phải tìm hiểu ấy. Chứ hồi trước
là đúng là tôi hồi trước tôi dùng
chattivity mà. Thế nên là kiểu
ừ tôi nghĩ là sẽ đến một thời điểm nào
đó. Thứ nhất là tôi không hề bị phomo,
không hề kiểu kiểu chạy theo công nghệ
hay là kiểu dạng là sợ là bị bỏ lại hay
các thứ thứ phải chạy theo xu hướng. Bở
vì có rất nhiều cái tôi vẫn chưa dùng.
Đấy nhưng mà tôi nghĩ là tôi từ khi tôi
kiểu đây sẽ đến một thời điểm nào đó là
ông sẽ phải thích nghi hoặc ông bị đảo
thải mà mình mang tiếng mình là dân công
nghệ là chuẩn là mình phải thích nghi
nhanh hơn người khác đúng không ạ? Dân
công nghệ mà mình lại bảo mình ngại hay
vân vân vân gì đó thì nó cũng hơi sai
đúng không ạ? Đấy
không tin đâu ạ. 5 năm trước anh em học
khóa của anh Long nè. Xin cảm ơn ạ. Bắt
đầu cái bài đồ án nhỉ.
bị gọi chữa cho bạn làm đồ án.
Đúng rồi. Tôi có đi dạy nếu mà mấy ông
có biết rồi. Hồi trước tôi từng đi dạy,
tôi từng làm giảng viên đấy. Thế nên là
tôi sẽ hỗ trợ định hướng cho các bạn
kiểu các bạn mà sinh viên đặc biệt là à
thậm chí là hôm trước tôi vừa chữa cho
bạn kể cả bạn đấy đi làm hình như cũng 5
6 năm gì ấy rồi bạn ấyã cần tôi t
vẫn sẵn sàng hỗ trợ
nói hỗ trợ miễn phí thì không biết mấy
hôm có tin không nhưng mà đại khái là
tôi rất là thoải mái
nên là ông nào mà cần thì nó là kiểu
dạng là kiểu như mình giúp người ta mình
vui à saong mình thêm kinh kinh nghiệm
thêm vốn kiến thức nữa cũng hay
sẽ ngồi gọi để mà trao đổi bạn đấy về
cái tôi sẽ ngồi chữa livestream như này
luôn cho bạn đấy về cái định hướng đồ
oán
không biết bạn đã on chưa cơ
Thường là chuẩn là sẽ tầm 8:00 hàng ngày
trừ khi có vướng lịch nào đó.
Có 100 ngày học Pon không bác? Tôi nghĩ
là tôi vẫn có một cái niềm gì đó không
thích PH lắm và lại cả là để làm gì đã.
Ví dụ giả sử tôi học Java này để chưa
biết được là liên quan công việc gì hay
không nhá. mà để mình đấy như tôi nói
lúc đầu là để học về cái sự chặt chẽ
xong rồi chuyên sâu về backend hay vân
vân vân này chứ không phải là để tôi học
quá nhiều ngôn ngữ bởi vì nó không để
làm gì cả.
ops là gì thế? Ơ cái cái có chấm nào à
đâu chỗ chỗ nào nhỉ?
ty tôi. Cái này kết nối sang kiểu
kiểu phải có phải mở cái này thì mới kết
nối được vào server công ty để tránh
việc là bây giờ ông nào cũng có IP là
được quyền truy cập thì không nên đúng
không ạ? Chỉ cần có IP mật khẩu mà truy
cập vào không nên. Thì bên này có hai
thằng th scale này này. Đấy.
đang nhảy job hả? Thực ra là không.
Nghĩa là thật ra là để mà nói thì
đại khái nó liên quan đến công một phần
là công ty mà một phần là kiểu à kiểu
đầu tiên thì có một người kiểu
à liên hệ tôi qua Lion xong rồi bảo
phỏng vấn thì rõ ràng tôi phỏng vấn và
thấy mọi thứ kiểu
khá là kiểu
không phải nói dùng từ trong mơ nhưng mà
nó khá là ổn đấy thì tôi có cân nhắc
xong rồi tôi cũng làm bài phỏng vấn các
thứ. Xong rồi khi mà làm bài phỏng vấn
xong thì họ mất tích. Đấy. Thế nên là
hôm trước tôi mới đăng cái video trên
kênh YouTube này là cái video tôi trả
lời bài phỏng vấn ấy. Đấy.
À thì nói chung là đại khái thì kiểu làm
bài phỏng vấn xong rồi trả lời cho người
ta xong mà bị kiểu
bị không phản hồi bị gớt à đấy bị bơ ấy
thì cũng khó chịu thật.
dùng PP cho dù rõ ràng là học Java thì
hôm qua ngồi nghe Java cũng thấy nghe
hay thật
không bởi vì tôi trả lời rất là chậm đấy
không ạ đi hát không anh
ok mấy anh em có gì anh em cứ lên kèo
sau
ông Minh Hiếu Ngô chung quen quen nhỉ
cuốn
hay W school về không? Không, tôi học
theo cái này này, học theo cái mà tôi đã
dùng AI để mà soạn bởi vì như tôi bảo
lúc đầu là tôi sẽ học từ cơ bản một tí
nhưng nó vẫn là đây
từ
PP
sang vân vân vân nên là
tập trung vào cái sự khác biệt vân vân
chứ không phải là nghĩa là có nhiều cái
là nghĩa là nếu mà bạn nào mà gọn như
thì những cái mà tôi chia sẻ sắp tới thế
này sẽ có thể rất là lạ vì rõ ràng là
cái này không phải là học từ cơ bản hoàn
toàn nhưng mà cái này nó sẽ là kiểu phù
hợp với việc là ông đang từ biết trước
một ngôn ngữ lập trình rồi ông nhảy sang
đấy kiểu
có nhiều người đây là tôi thấy giống như
kiểu lần đầu bình luận ấy. Trông rất lạ
luôn.
các bạn xem video kia cũng chắc biết tên
công ty tôi không tiện nhắc tên. Mình
không mình cũng bị ảnh hưởng cảm xúc bởi
công ty đấy. Vì công ty kiểu cho mình có
một tí suy nghĩ gì đó kiểu đán đo thôi.
Hôm đấy tôi đán đo cực các thứ thứ nghĩ
nhiều cực cuối cùng bị gớt hơi buồn.
Ai ai giờ cũng phải thích nghi thôi. Ok
24 giờ đi anh 100 ngày hơi lâu. 100 ngày
mới thể hiện quyết tâm lẫn cả là mình
mới gọi là như này mình mới
kiểu thấm nhuần nhập nó được vào đầu ấy.
Còn nếu mà học theo kiểu là giống kiểu
hackaton hay kiểu là kiểu học kiểu try
hot kiểu như thế thì
nó sẽ không đọng lại hết vào trong đầu
được. Đấy kiểu thế.
lệch không? Bởi vì tôi đang trả lời từng
cái ở trên cùng mà nên là nó chậm thông
cảm. Công ty cấp Copilot nhưng không
dùng
nhưng không cho dùng cloud
off vì đắt. Đúng ờ
đắt nhất mà cho dù là tôi thấy thằng
Winsert có một cái hai cực.
đắn đo khi mà kiểu rời xa nó bởi vì nó
thằng Vinf nó có cái AI tự nó phát triển
ra. Tôi không nhớ gì hình như chính cái
W vừa nãy hay cái gì đó ấy. Nó đại khái
là nó hiển thị rõ bảng giá ở đây nhá.
Hiển thị rõ bảng giá là ví dụ là con này
mất bao nhiêu credit, con này mất bao
nhiêu credit đúng không? Con này là mất
giả sử con này mất tận ba credit đi. Mấy
con kia chỉ một hay hai đúng không?
Nhưng cái con AI của thằng Vinus này tự
ra nhá. Cứ cho là tên nó là A đi. Tôi
không nhớ lắm. Nó chỉ mất 0,5 credit
thôi.
Và rõ ràng khi mà AI của nhà làm được
thì rõ ràng là nó sẽ
nó sẽ có thể không ngon bằng thằng Cloue
đang rất là xịn bây giờ đúng không?
Nhưng nó sẽ chơi một cái trò nữa đó là
cộng với thằng Cloue
con đấy vẫn là ba credit đi. Nhưng mà
cộng này tức là sao? Nghĩa là chỉ là cái
này rất phù hợp cho những anh em nào
thậm chí kể cả tôi thường đó là tôi
không muốn hỏi mấy con quá quỷ bắp bởi
vì có những cái mình đầu tiên mình vẫn c
độ chính xác đúng không? Thế nên là mình
vẫn phải hỏi những cái con mà chắc chắn
sẽ trả lời cho mình chính xác. Nhưng con
đấy tốn quá nhiều credit thì bâyế giờ nó
có sinh ra cái vụ này hay phết. Đó là
những
câu mà thằng đấy chắc chắn sẽ trả lời
được. Ví dụ con này chắc chắn sẽ trả
được luôn thì nó sẽ phản hồi rất nhanh.
này phản hồi nhanh lắm như kiểu chavity
kiểu mình gõ vừa gõ nó xong nó đã phản
hồi luôn ý đấy đấy trong trường hợp nó
trả lời được và nó tốn chỉ 0,5 credit
thôi. Nhưng với những câu nào mà nó sẽ
tự đánh giá, nó cảm thấy khó, nó sẽ tự
viết prom để hỏi lại con này và lúc đấy
nó mới bắt đầu tốn ba credit. Ông hiểu ý
tưởng đúng không ạ? Nghĩa rất là hay.
Nghĩa lúc đấy đúng hồi mà tôi dùng cái
đấy, tôi sẽ chẳng cần quan tâm đến việc
là tôi phải dùng cái model nào, phải cân
nhắc, phải đổi mod liên tục như hiện tại
là kiểu cái này đỡ tốn hơn cái này các
thứ thứ trong trường hợp này trường hợp
kia. Không, tôi sẽ chỉ dùng con này
thôi. Nghĩa là
nếu nó trả lời được nhanh mà vẫn phải
chính xác, vẫn chính xác nhá. Đấy thì nó
trả lời luôn tôi tốn rất ít mà Queens
gần đây nó còn tăng cho lượng credit là
tận 500 credit thì phải. Hồi trước là
250 bằng 15 đô đấy. Đấy đây là mỗi tháng
15 đô sẽ được 500 credit. Sau đó thì 250
credit cho 10 đô tiếp theo.
Nghĩa là bạn top up nạp thêm ấy. Đấy
nhưng mà 500 cái bây giờ ông cứ hình
dung giả sử bài toán lý tưởng nhất là
ông làm cái project kiểu rất đơn giản cơ
bản toàn dễ và trưởng nhưng ông muốn
dùng ai code đúng không? Đấy thì 500
credit này ngang bằng 1000 lần ông hỏi
câu này 1000 lần hỏi 1 tháng ông hỏi thế
phải tầm 1 ngày ông hỏi hơn 30 lần
một tháng hơn 1 ngày hơn 30 cái prom để
hỏi liên tục ai cũng tẹt gam mà đúng
không đấy
nếu mà so bài toán của ông với resarch
này 60 đô của ông là tôi còn dùng tẹt
mấy tháng rồi.
research kiểu qua thôi nhá. Rõ ràng nãy
giờ tôi khen anti gravity nhiều hơn mà
tôi còn chưa chia sẻ link ra đ mấy ông
đâu. Đấy chia sẻ link ra biết đâu cộng
được cái gì không.
ờ đừng, nếu mà em còn đang nạp tiền chớ
thì thôi bỏ đi thằng này bằng giá cho nó
ngon hơn. À đấy trong trường hợp em
không dùng chích gì đó để mà mua đấy
nên đại khái thì ờ ông cứ phải dùng thử
đã. Tôi chỉ nói thế thôi chứ tôi chẳng
ăn được cái gì.
về AI. Ừ, hình như là tôi tham gia mấy
cái nhóm kiểu thế nhưng mà tôi kiểu lười
kiểu và theo dõi chat các thứ ấ nên tôi
không để ý lắm.
buổi đi coi. Ok. Ok được. T scale đó
dùng ổn không anh? Thứ nhất là nó đang
miễn phí, thứ hai là nó không phải là
VPN để mà mấy ông kết nối vân vân gì
đâu. Tôi hiện tại tôi đang dùng chỉ kết
nối đến con server ở trên công ty nên là
nó không có vấn đề gì cả. Không không có
vấn đề phát sinh. Kiểu mở lên mà dùng
thôi. Không bị cái tình trạng bị delay
hay mọi thứ gì cả. Nhưng không biết là
mấy ông dùng việc khác như thế nào nhá.
Phỏng vấn xong mất tích chắc hoan man
lắm. Ơ thì gửi cho người ta bài làm mình
xong xong người ta tôi gửi xong không
thấy phản hồi qua mail tôi nhắn tin qua
lúc đầu hồi trước nhắn tin qua leon này
xong còn nhắn tin qua WhatsApp này không
được này xong rồi tuần sau tôi lại gửi
mail thêm phát nữa để hỏi kiểu xác nhận
lại vẫn không thể có phối gì cả thực ra
là tôi stock được à nick tôi start được
hình như nick của chị quản lý ở bên đấy
rồi cơ
nhưng mà kiểu nick Facebook ấy nh thôi
bây giờ mình bây giờ chẳng lẽ mình lại
inbox nói người ta m kiểu nói chung là
thôi đành kệ vậy biết sao giờ cùng lắm
là ư nhỉ
mình phải bắt trượng ông kia tôi đang
nói là tôi không đang định tôi không
định đăng phố lên J2 thì nó lại hơi nặng
nề quá nhưng mà tôi đã từng đọc một cái
review về công ty đấy một cái thôi nhá
mới chỉ có một cái đây Đ mấy tháng là
công ty đã từng làm thế với với người ta
là từng cho người ta làm bạch kiểm tra
xong gớ. Ừ tôi sắp có một cái review thứ
hai giống thế rồi
được chứ bây giờ không ai nói kiểu tôi
thì tôi cảm thấy là vẫn nên có một tí
lên tiếng đúng không ạ? Để cho tránh
người khác bị giống mình. Đấy thực ra nó
chưa chắc là có thể người ta tìm được
người tốt hơn rồi hoặc vân vân gì đấy
người ta không thích mình đấy nhưng mà
mình vẫn nên nói.
đăng phút suốt
Zalo mà điển hình à. Thôi mẹ nói cả tên
mất rồi. Không có gì nhá. Không có gì
nhá. Kênh này nó không trụ nổi như
nhóm Facebook, nó dễ bay hơn đấy.
nhá. Tôi học Java không dạy
nhầm nhá. Tôi ghi ở đây 100 ngày học
Java mà không dậy nhá.
ta chuẩn bị bắt đầu học. Ừ, đáng lẽ nãy
giờ không học cái gì lộ lỡ tôi mải nói
chuyện quá. Cho xem lộ trình á. À đây
đây đây để tôi a để link cho anh em. Cái
này là tôi dùng
à tôi dùng cái a tổng hợp ra dựa trên
cái kiến thức có sẵn của tôi là là có
kinh nghiệm về PP rồi nhá. Chứ không
không phải là kiểu mấy ông cứ học như
này thì sẽ ổn đâu nhá. Tất cả chỉ mang
tính chất tham khảo ạ. Đấy
được ông ông kia nói câu hay vãi chưởng
học đi ông để tôi xem cách ông học đấy
tôi rất cần những người như thế để tôi
đỡ mật tôi chung để tôi ngồi học và
chúng ta cùng hồi học mà cái livestream
này chúng ta cùng hồi học nhá không ai
dạy được ai đâu
à nhầm ông có thể dạy tôi như tôi không
dạy được ông chắc chắn
ok xem
đây tôi ghim cái link kia cho mấy ông
nhá. Ok
link đấy cũng là do thằng em ngồi làm ra
cho tôi ấy chứ không phải là của một
giáo án của một thầy nào đó hay vân vân
gì đâu nhá anh em. Tất cả chị màn hình
rất tham khảo
cảm giác quay về thời dịch.
Tôi cũng PP muốn học. Ok chúng ta học
cùng nhau nào.
không thế lại quá nhầm rồi. Không có
người giỏi nào ở đây cả. Chúng ta nếu mà
người giỏi thì chúng ta đi dậy rồi chứ
không phải chúng ta đi học.
Lại tí làm hộm nước ạ. Xin phép.
anh có dành về React không? Gần đây tôi
mới có động vào ở trên công ty nhưng tôi
không dành đấy. Kể cả hồi trước tôi từng
làm view nhưng tôi vẫn không dành. Tôi
tự tin là tôi dành về PP hết à một tí về
SQL đấy.
Dùng Nest DS chưa? Tôi cũng chưa luôn ạ.
dịch thì cái này bỏ qua hả thầy? Ờ ông
chưa qua vì do gì đã. Nếu mà ông chưa
qua vì ông cảm thấy ghét lập trình thì
ông cũng không nên xem video này.
Đúng đúng đúng. Đấy một trong những cái
tôi cảm thấy là mấy người khác không
dùng AI cảm thấy lãng phí. Thôi đây bắt
đầu học nhá.
Thì hôm qua
bắt ngồi dậy tôi viết câu lệnh mà
hôm qua tôi học được bài này rồi phải
không ạ? Đấy à đầu tiên thì cài ông em
cho lên trang chủ xong phải đăng nhập
cái gì gì đó để cài nhưng tôi không cài
cái Intel Leg này đâu. Xin tạm biệt.
Xong rồi tiếp theo
là để phân biệt hai cái này. Ông em dịch
cái này là nguyên thủy và cái này là
kiểu class đóng uống gói. Ờ xong rồi kèm
theo mấy cái kiểu dữ liệu. Thì hôm qua
tôi thử tạo một file như này.
cho mấy ông nhá. Ông nào thấy tôi nói
sai cứ cứ chấn chỉnh nhá.
Thì Java thì nó sẽ là kiểu chuyên trong
các class class ấy. Đấy. Đấy. Thì tôi
tạo một cái class như này. Ok. Và trong
đó có một cái luôn
luôn có một cái co à luôn có một cái
kiểu method là main như thế này để mà
chạy. Thường là mọi thứ sẽ chạy nằm
trong này đúng không ạ?
Đấy. Ờ
thì ở đây sẽ có hai cái là bình thường
với PP thì mình không có kiểu khai báo
kiểu dữ liệu như này. Mình sẽ đô la
thẳng luôn đúng không ạ? Còn trong Java
thì mình sẽ có khai báo kiểu dữ liệu.
Đấy thì khai báo kiểu dữ liệu thì theo
kiểu nguyên thủy thì tức là mình kiểu in
này xong rồi ờ kiểu chuỗi à ừ xong rồi
kiểu bull này vân vân string các thứ
đúng không ạ? Thì nhưng mà bên này nó sẽ
có thêm một nữa là nếu mà ghi kiểu viết
hoa đấy, viết hoa viết đầy đủ như này
thì nó sẽ là một class. Cái này là một
class. Đấy, hôm qua tôi mới tự khai sáng
từ bản thân mình ra. Đây là một class.
Và đương nhiên đương nhiên class này nó
sẽ có thêm ngoài những method có trong
này. Đấy, thì nó sẽ được phép đặt cái
giá trị là nun. Còn nếu mà in thì bình
thường không được nol. Đấy.
Đây nếu mà trong PP thì hồi trước có cái
trò kiểu hỏi chấm như này thì
để một là in hai là nun. Nhưng mà trong
này không được mấy không ạ?
nhá. Nên là tôi sẽ so sánh PP rất là
nhiều nên là mấy ông mà chưa biết cả PP
thì chịu nhá.
Thiếu
generic rồi. Generic là gì? Mấy ông nhắc
đến generic mà tôi không biết.
Thôi xong để xem nào. Chick đúng không?
Ch
gen r
cho anh em rồi anh em vào tự cập nhật
vào trong đấy rồi chúng ta sẽ có buổi
hôm sau rồi học về cái đấy nhá. Ok. Đấy
thì hôm qua tôi tôi giả sử tôi thử viết
quá
xong rồi tôi còn à so sánh cái này nữa.
Hôm qua so sánh cái này trông kiểu vô lý
vãi. Kiểu tự nhiên đây là in nhỏ hơn
long này 64 bit các thứ thứ đúng không?
So tự nhiên flot lại lớn hơn long mà rõ
ràng cái này 32 bit. Đấy, hôm qua tôi
phải thắc mắc thắc mắc hai lần liền để
nó phải xác nhận lại với tôi là cái này
là liên quan đến khoảng giá trị và nó
hay nó dùng cái cơ chế dấu phẩy động.
Cái này tôi từng nghe qua thôi, tôi nghĩ
nó không chém gió đâu. Nhưng là cái này
tôi nghĩa là về sau tôi động được đến.
quen quen nhỉ? Ý ông cái này á.
Đây á kiểu như này á
ông lừa tôi đúng không?
kiểu dữ được đâu.
dùng thình kinh đấy.
quá
nên là chúng ta sẽ dùng
đây
tôi
đang học Java
có người bảo
nữa nó là gì cập nhật vào tiến trình học
cho tôi. gì
ông nói một kiểu đấy ông bịp tôi đúng
không?
Đây đúng kiểu dạng
đấy. Đây đúng kiểu dạng kiểu
cậy người ta không biết gì nói đấy.
Someone subet kiểu generic in Java. Đây
đây đây cái tôi đang muốn nói này nó sẽ
hiển thị ra cái luồng suy nghĩ khá từng
minh này để mình biết này
đang nói tiếng Việt các thứ các thứ dịch
xong rồi nó tự xịch ra hạ vậy chưa đây
đọc này đấy nó sẽ nói cái luồng nó sẽ
làm này đúng không đọc này xong rồi đọc
hiểu này
giải thích nó là gì này cập nhật lại này
đấy tôi hiểu rồi thìẽ tham số hóa kiểu
Tiếng Việt nó dịch ra nó cũng không dễ
hiểu lắm nhỉ. Cho phép viết code với
nhiều kiểu dự khác nhau nhưng đảm bảo à.
Nó giống như kiểu à
kiểu như này đúng không? Kiểu nếu trong
PP nó sẽ kiểu như này đúng không? Đấy
kiểu kiểu như này. Nghĩa là có thể một
trong hai đúng không?
Đúng không? V xem nào.
toàn. Đâu xem
ơ thằng này có một nhược điểm đó là mình
đang cuộn lên trên như thế.
Mình đang cuộn lên trên như thế xong
mình cứ kiểu nó tự động viết nó lại kéo
mất cái cuộn mình. Có thật
đấy. Nó bị cuộn cuộn cách hiện đại an
toàn. Cái này chỉ khai báo kiểu dữ liệu
cho array danh sách thôi mà đúng không?
đây? Tham số hóa kiểu cho viết code làm
việc nhiều kiểu dữ an toàn. Bình thường
là đúng rồi. Mảng của PP nó rất nhiều
vấn đề như này đúng không? Ok tôi biết.
Xong rồi. Nếu mà kiểu array kiểu như này
à cái này tôi biết mà. Cái cái kiểu lên
cái danh sách kiểu arist này hay array
một cái gì đó rồi bắt buộc kiểu dữ liệu
trong đấy phải bắt buộc bằng kiểu gì
giống kiểu high script thôi mà.
Thế tôi biết tôi từng biết high script
rồi nhá.
Thế nó có đâu liên quan cái tôi đang học
đâu.
Mấy ông lừa lắm.
generic.
thì cái phần op kia chỉ xem chỉ trong
một ngày thôi. Đúng như là tôi đang nói
tôi muốn học từ đầu để mà thực sự biết
được mình có hổng cái gì không. Hôm qua
tôi hỏi ông em ông em mang tiếng nhiều
năm kinh nghiệm về Java rồi nhá. dùng e
nhiều xong rồi kiểu có nhiều cái cũng
phải ngồi tự kiểu khi mà ông thực sự
ông kiểu làm theo thói quen rồi ấy nhưng
mà để mà ông thực sự phải hiểu để đi dạy
người khác thì nó một trường hợp hoàn
toàn khác nhá lúc đấy kiến thức ông sẽ
phải khác bởi vì ông nói giống như kiểu
bây giờ nói cho một đứa trẻ con một cái
vài điều mà ông có hiển nhiên ấy ông sẽ
phải thực sự phải hiểu theo một cái cách
cách khác để mà nói đấy kiểu
động.
tôi chưa biết cách viết như ông muốn đâu
nha. Ok. Thế chắc là cuối buổi này tôi
sẽ gọi cho bạn riêng sau.
À tưởng model nào cũng có luồng suy nghĩ
thế này
không? Model nào cũng có luồng suy nghĩ
như này thì đúng. Nhưng là tôi đang nói
là nếu mà ông dùng core ấy tôi thấy là
không có hiển thị ra cái thót suy nghĩ
luồng suy nghĩ vừa rồi đâu. Đấy thế nên
tôi mới dùng antigravity hoặc là winsert
thì nó hiển thị ra cái đấy.
thì chỉ viết một lần đấy. Không phải
viết hai hàm.
Cái này tôi nghe hình như là nó liên
quan đến tái sử dụng của hàm nữa thì
phải. Ok. Nhưng cứ bình tĩnh bình tĩnh
đã chưa học bên học 11 đã bình tĩnh.
nước mưa đấy. À không phải nước mưa mà
tiếng các bạn nh máy nước bơm ở trên rồi
nó cứ bị tràn nước mà.
unboxing. Đúnging hôm qua tôi cũng thấy
có đề cập ở trong này.
Đâu rồi? Cái từ unboxing đâu rồi?
Nó có đề cập trong này này. Auto boxing
này. Đấy đây đây đây. Thực ra cái auto
boxing này hôm qua tôi có dịch ra ấy.
Tôi hiểu là kiểu nếu mà gán như này thì
nó sẽ hiểu là gán vào cái value của nó
thì phải. Đấy thằng em tôi nói là như
thế.
cái archiving value của nó. Đấy, nghĩa
đây là một cái class nhưng mà khi mà ghi
như này sẽ hiểu là gán tự động gán vào
cái value của nó.
May có chữa không ạ? Ừ, chắc là tí tôi
vẫn sẽ chữa bạn thôi.
Biết high script thì tương đương với
Java à anh?
Ừ thì thực ra tôi nghĩ là tôi học thì
cho biết thôi. Xem à mấy cái đoạn này
chắc là mấy ông biết rồi
về cái double hay các thứ thứ trên này
thì nó cũng code để nói về cách khai báo
thôi. Thường à
nó viết hoa lên nó sẽ thành theo như tôi
đang hiểu thế nó viết hoa lên nó sẽ
thành một cái class và nó sẽ không còn
đơn thuần là kiểu dữ liệu nữa mà nó là
một cái class hơn. Đấy ngoài ra nó sẽ
dùng được những cái hàm hôm qua tôi dùng
thử mà. Đây ví dụ giả sử tôi dùng thử
cái hàm à đây thằng D này đúng không?
Đây tôi cho đây tôi viết hẳn hàm cạnh
thằng D đi cho dễ hiểu. Đây
à
hôm hôm qua tôi thử dùng cái hàm này
nhá.
hình chẳng hạn.
Đấy, tức là tức là kiểu thằng này thằng
class nên nó có những cái method, có
những cái hàm kiểu như thế này. Đấy,
đương nhiên là làm gì có chuyện thằng C
có thể gọi class kiểu tương đương như
thế này được. Nó sẽ báo lỗi này. Đấy,
mang tiếng là không phải IE nhưng mà nó
cũng tự động bắt báo lỗi là thằng này
thì nó chỉ đơn giản là kiểu nó là số
thôi nên là nó không thể gọi được những
hàm khác. Nó sẽ chỉ có giá trịể so sánh
các thứ thứ kiểu so sánh toán tử thôi
đúng không ạ? Đ như này thôi đúng không
ạ? Nhưng mà thằng D này thì nó sẽ có
những cái hàm khác nữa. Đấy kiểu kiểu
như thế bởi nó một class nó sẽ có những
mớ vân vân. Ui cháy.
mình là từ thời đầu đấy.
Xin chào bạn. Hi vọng các bạn à cảm thấy
là nó có ích. Mình thì mình thì vui khi
được dậy. Do dù là mình vẫn cố phấn đấu
là nó sẽ giúp được các bạn gì đó nhưng
mà đấy là phân đấu mình thôi. Nếu mà
phải thực sự đem lại giá trị các bạn thì
mình mới cảm thấy kiểu xứng đáng ấy đúng
không ạ?
À đấy giả sử mình viết cái class như này
xong đúng không ạ? Thì hôm qua mình được
dạy là sẽ là dùng cái javác như này này.
Xong rồi đặt xong rồi gọi tên của nó. À
hôm qua cũng bị nhầm nữa cơ. Cái này nằm
trong thư mục này là phải CD 1 này 5 này
xong rồi Java
xong rồi price. Cái này tab một cái đúng
không ạ?
Đây như này à phải ghi đầy đủ chấm java
đấy. Ơ vẫn báo lỗi à báo lỗi
tại cái B này.
Xem nào. Vừa nãy gõ à vừa nãy gõ ở đoạn
này sai rồi. Cộng
không có B ở đây chỉ có C thôi. Ok.
Ok.
Cái này nó sẽ tự động tạo ra cái thằng à
chấm class này. Class này kiểu nó là
file đã biên dịch đấy. Xong mình sẽ chạy
cái file này là Java
như này.
Đấy. Đấy. Nó sẽ in ra kết quả các thứ.
Cái này dùng season out nó kiểu in mà
đúng không?
ra
nếu mà đọc cái file class này tôi cảm
thấy kiểu trông nó đúng kiểu nó không
phải file code nên mình hơi khó đọc đúng
không ạ?
xong chưa nhưng hôm qua tôi đã khá biết
qua về cái vụ bên đấy. Tiếp theo là
phân biệt các thứ hiểu về string pool.
người nào dạy tôi ở đây ngay thời điểm
này nên tôi sẽ chơi trò tôi sẽ dùng cái
AI để dậy.
Anh em có gì thông cảm nhé. Đấy tôi sẽ
đây.
Hôm trước là tôi nhớ cái người ta khuyên
khi mà dùng AI ấy thì mấy ông biết mấy
cái con Thinh Kingh này rồi đúng không?
Con Thing Kingh này ngoài việc bảo nó
thông minh ra ấy thì tức cả cái từ kinh
là thể hiện việc là nó sẽ nghĩ. Thế nên
là mình mà càng kiểu ra lệnh những cái
prom nó rất là chi tiết và rất là chặt
chẽ làm cho nó không phải nghĩ làm cho
nó bị kiểu bó hẹp vào những cái
những cái mà ông muốn làm nên là có thể
là nó sẽ giới hạn khả năng của nó. Chuẩn
là ông sẽ chỉ nên nhập input và output
thôi. Nghĩa là nhập đầu vào là gì này và
mong muốn kết quả là gì. Đấy, xong rồi
nó sẽ tự nó sẽ tự kiểu nghĩ cách để mà
nghĩ giai đoạn code, nghĩ cách để làm ra
được cái kết quả như thế. Đương nhiên là
có thể nó sẽ không đúng cách mà mấy ông
muốn. Đấy, do mới có khái niệm planing
này. Nghĩa là trong những cái trường hợp
là khó hoặc là ông chỉ cần bảo nó là hãy
viết ra để tôi confirm lại đã, tôi xác
nhận lại đã thì mới được làm. Đấy, thì
tránh việc đợi thời gian hay mất công gì
đó. đúng không ạ? Nhưng mà nói chung là
dùng mấy con thình kinh này nên là để
cho nó nghĩ mình ra lệnh ngắn thôi. Còn
nếu mình ra lệnh dài quá nó giới hạn khả
năng của nó thì mình đã dùng mấy con cơ
bản nó nhanh. Đấy,
nếu thế chứng tỏ với chính mình là người
chọn cái chọn cái thình kinh mà tức là
chính mình là người nghĩ nhiều và nghĩ
rằng là nó nên nghĩ nhiều so bây giờ ông
lại bảo nó nghĩ nhiều thì đấy là lỗi của
mình đấy chứ đúng không? Đấy mình chỉ
chọn những con cơ bản để làm những cái
việc cơ bản thôi. Còn những cái việc còn
nâng cao việc phải suy nghĩ nhiều. Ví dụ
là nhiều lúc là tôi bắt nó đọc gần như
là cả project đấy để mà nói về cái luồng
một cái luồng ở đó thì tôi dùng mấy cái
con kiểu như này còn không bình thường
không. Đây tôi cứ dùng con này cho dễ
nha. Hoặc con Jini này tôi cảm thấy con
Jim Mini này nghĩ như không nghĩ thế nên
có dừng nói những cái đơn giản. Ô ok.
à. Đấy, hôm qua ông em có ngồi nhắc về
cái khái niệm về quản lý bộ nhớ
hip này ở trong Java. Kiểu bình thường
mình dùng PP thì mình sẽ ít để ý về cái
bộ nhớ lắm. Kiểu nó sẽ ít khái niệm là
kiểu tràn bộ nhớ rồi các thứ thứ. Xong
rồi Java cũng phải quản lý bộ nhớ tốt
hơn đấy đúng không ạ? ngay việc khai báo
đã kiểu khai báo kiểu
kiểu nói chung là khai báo đã thể hiện
phần nào về cái quan tâm về bộ nhớ rồi
đúng không ạ?
quen thuộc này. Đã có chỗ này chưa? Nếu
có thì trả về reference chưa tạo mới thì
ồ cái này hay phết nhỉ.
Đấy, không học cơ bản làm sao mà hiểu
được những cái như này.
mấy ông toàn mấy ông biết rồi vào kiểu
nói kiểu gọi như là mấy ông chỉ nói tôi
đúng hay sai thôi. Bây giờ mấy ông nói
thế là tôi kiểu tôi không biết được à.
Nó sẽ bị kiểu
gọi như nà nhỉ. Đấy giống kiểu
overthinking giống như ông kia vừa nói
sẽ bị overlúng không? Nó quá tải kiến
thức cùng một lúc. Buổi một thì tôi học
tôi cảm thấy thế là rất là vui rồi. À
đây buổi hai nhầm có lưu lại stream nhá.
Ông có thể tôi lại cũng được nhá.
nặng lớn giống như hồi trước tôi làm
file Excel cũng có đấy. Ngồi read Excel
là một chuyện ngồi WR ra file Excel
chết. Xong rồi hồi đấy là dùng cái thư
viện nữa Larel kết hợp với Excel nữa. Ui
xong rồi về sau không dùng thư viện nữa.
Dùng hết hàm thuần của PP thì nó mới
nhanh. và lẫn cả trò là
kiểu một loạn nói chung là dùng hạp
thuần ấy nó là dùng bài toán con trò ấy
kiểu trò đến các thứ thứ để mà ghi thêm
dữ liệu thôi chứ không phải ngồi mở lại
cả cái file đấy. Bởi vì cái thư viện kia
là ông hình dung thư viện đấy cứ mỗi lần
gọi đến nó mở lại cả cái file xong nó
ghi thêm vào xong rồi đóng vai thế nên
chết đấy bởi vì loát cả cái file ra thì
chẳng chết RAM đúng không ạ? Đấy,
phân biệt string videoer và string
buffer. Ok, để tôi nốt lại luôn. Cảm ơn
nhé. Ok.
À lưu
tôi thêm về string builder đúng không?
Và string buffer đấy
đúng không ạ? Ok.
Đấy để nó tự soạn cho tôi.
Dùng AI để dạy mình.
là thầy
PP à đâu à đang học note có theo luôn
khóa này không thầy không cái này tôi
đang tự học nhá tôi cho mấy ông vào học
cùng cho vui thôi chứ chứ tôi không
khuyên mấy ông học kiểu dạng như nào
mấy ông bỏ cái này để sang học cùng tôi
hay gì gì đó mấy ông cứ học cái của mấy
ông đang tốt đã mấy ông xem cái này tham
khảo thôi chủ yếu. Mà mấy ông biết thì
mấy ông dạy tôi nữa đấy. Quá tuyệt vời
chứ tôi trong cái khóa này tôi là người
học chứ tôi không dạy thìì mấy ông đâu
nhá.
Ok nó phải ra một cái các thứ các thứ tí
xem sau. Đấy đây đây đây. Trong trường
hợp mà nó thấy phức tạp hơn một tí là nó
bắt đầu viết ông cái tab toolit này.
Xong rồi rất nhiều lúc là nó ghi hẳn cái
plan rồi các thứ. Và một trong những cái
hay nữa của nó so với việc là tôi dùng
quị Vinser hồi trước phải tạo file Mdown
ấy, đó là cái này có comment đúng không
ạ? Đấy, comment vào đây là tao không
muốn thế này chẳng hạn, tao muốn kiểu
khác vân vân vân. Đấy, comment vào đây
thì cái này mới càng thể hiện rõ. Giống
như là mình bây giờ không còn là coder
mấy nữa. Mình là PM là mình là người sẽ
giao việc và quản lý
kiểu review lại code này, review cách nó
code, review luồng nó suy nghĩ này vân
vân vân. Đấy.
à cái G này là tôi tự ghi thôi. Cái file
này file tôi tự ghi ấ mà để lên cái
kế hoạch học mà nếu mà xem trông giao
diện kiểu này chắc là đẹp hơn này.
lắm.
Tôi tôi xem chắc là tôi xem quen kiểu
bên này rồi. Thông cảm.
phải rõ cái hit với stack trong Java nào
nữa. Đấy, ông này lại nói thêm một từ
mới tôi không biết kìa. Stack à? Ồ, ok.
Stack là hình như là stack giống cái
kill đúng không?
Ừ không phải giống cái kill nhưng ý tôi
là kiểu kiểu nó cũng thường đi với kill
ấy. Kiểu một cái trong PP thì đương
nhiên chúng ta làm việc với kill rồi.
Một cái kìa first in first out đúng
không? Stack là tôi nhớ là first in l
out đúng không? Giống kiểu như cái trong
đĩa mà đúng không?
Còn hit là gì? Tôi chưa biết đâu. Đấy.
Đấy. Đây.
thêm cho tôi về hit và stack. Không biết
là gì cứ nốt lại thôi.
kiểu chấm chấm chấm. Ok. Xem nào. Tất cả
trỏ đều cùng một object trong string
boo. Hả? Kiểu gì vậy? Hello. Này
đâu có tạo bằng littal tạo bằng ba chấm
đâu. Địp à.
Này đều khai báo bình thường mà nhỉ.
sánh
bình thường là so sánh giá trị mà nhỉ.
Bây giờ trong trường hợp này so sánh địa
chỉ bộ nhớ à? Uầi
vãi.
Cái này liên quan đến kiểu địa chỉ bộ
nhớ của con trỏ các thứ. À
Ok. Tôi có thể xem mà.
À đây khai báo kiểu như này sẽ là khai
báo kiểu dùng trong tôi cứ tưởng lal là
cái ba chấm này ạ. [tiếng cười] Nó là
cái dấu nháy này. Ok ok ok.
Đấy,
nghĩa là kiểu khai báo kiểu như này thì
tất cả ba thằng đang trò về chung chung
một cái bộ nhớ thành ra giá trị nó sẽ
giá trị bằng nhau. Nhưng mà cái việc hai
dấu bằng này mà so sánh địa chỉ bốn nhớ
thì tôi đang hơi thắc mắc thô không sao.
Còn đây khai báo hẳn một thằng mới à
giống kiểu một cái đối tượng mới. Đây
khai báo trong PP sẽ new object đúng
không? Một đối tượng mới. Đúng rồi,
object mới đây. Ok. trong híp. Đấy, lại
tạo thêm một object nữa. Uầy, đấy, AI nó
tự viết ra các thứ thứ trông cũng hay mà
đúng không? Đấy, bây giờ AI cá nhân hóa
việc học hành.
Uầy, ba hai dấu bằng bây giờ là so sánh
địa chỉ ạ, không phải là giá trị. À ui,
đúng rồi. Bởi vì đây là chuỗi đúng
không? Nếu mà chuỗi thì sẽ phải dùng cái
Tôi nhớ là chuỗi phải dùng string equal
đúng không? Tôi nhớ là thế.
Đúng rồi. Uầy ui mình còn biết trước bài
này. Thông cảm tôi đang tự học nên tôi
sẽ hơi tự khen bản thân hơi tự luyến một
tí.
Mấy ông đã học kiêm túc thì mấy ông sẽ
không thích cho lắm.
nhớ.
Cái này tôi bảo rồi ông nào mà học PP mà
nhảy sang đây học cùng tôi cảm thấy cũng
choáng như tôi thôi. Kiểu cái này kiểu
khai sáng ấy. Đấy
cái này chắc chắn là phải kiểu
tôi nghĩ là bắt buộc là phải có một cái
ấn tượng kiểu như thế. Ấn tượng như tôi
vừa bày tỏ cảm xúc ấy thì nó mới nhớ
hình sâu dung sâu trong đầu được chứ cái
này dễ quên lắm vì mình đang có code gì
đâu. Mình có đang thực hành gì đâu.
rồi. Tôi nhớ thế.
New string. Cái cái này chắc là không có
thể à đâu cái S6 này cũng có thể chấm
equal được này. Tôi đang tưởng là à cái
này là không phải nguyên thủy nhở. Con
này cũng là class rồi. Con này không
được nhỉ.
Đây như này được đúng không? À cha tôi
nhớ cha là phải là
cha tôi nhớ nó là phải là khai báo giống
kiểu m đúng không nhỉ?
Đây kiểu như này nhở bốn ký tự chẳng hạn
đúng không?
từng từng cái từng cái nhỉ.
kiểu này được mà đúng không? Không được
à?
Hay là string xong rồi như này mới được.
Tôi nhớ có một cái là khai báo cái a
hỏi tôi tự vỡ ra nãy giờ ấy chứ.
khai đấy. Tôi nhớ có khai báo con cái
này mà
xem nào.
Đây à.
nhiêu. Hồi trước tôi nhớ là phải khai
báo là có ba kiểu tối đa bao nhiêu ấy.
Tôi không khai báo nữa à.
mà đúng không? Không thấy bao lỗi gì cả.
Tôi nhớ có một thằng bắt buộc phải khai
báo là độ dài của mảng là bao nhiêu ấy,
độ dài của chuỗi là bao nhiêu chẳng hạn.
Thế
theo cái mảng cán cho đúng không? Nhưng
mà bây giờ giả sử tôi để như này thì tôi
đang thấy không báo lỗi gì cả thì rốt
cuộc thằng này nó như nào? Nó có báo lỗi
gì không?
không nhỉ? Thử xem nhá.
constant à? Ừ. Constant này hơi vô nghĩa
nhỉ. Sân này chẳng có giá trị gì đúng
không?
tôi biết khái niệm về constant nhưng mà
bọn tôi không khai báo constant như thế
mà tôi phải khai báo nó là constant thì
tức là nó mới constant.
Nói chung là không sao. Cái vừa rồi tôi
mới gọi là nhớ lại thừ kiến thức cũ
thôi. Coi như là mình chưa biết gì nhá.
Mình học từ đầu mà. Ok
thì tôi vẫn sẽ có thắc mắc là thằng à
bởi vì thằng này là thằng wpper class
đúng không? Nên nó sẽ có hàm này. Đấy.
Ok. Thằng này chắc tương tự nhỉ? Thử 7
6. Ừ. Th cũng tương tự này. Thế ừ new
string này. Chắc là hai thằng string này
là class giống nhau rồi nhỉ.
String class.
Ừ. Hai thằng này là một rồi.
lừa tôi đúng không?
đâu
đúng không?
Ừ tôi hiểu ý không? Có thể là tra thì nó
sẽ là có tra này không? Không không có
lú nhỉ.
String chỉ là một object, một class thôi
đúng không? Ok. Ơ có gậy có các thứ thứ
này đây. Nó cũng bằng tra này.
Nhưng thằng tra này chắc là nó sẽ không
có.
hàm có sẵn trong mọi class. Tôi đang tôi
đang lúc đầu tôi tưởng là string này
cũng là một thằng grapper class
nhưng mà không thằng này chỉ là một
class bình thường thôi đúng không?
Ok để thử thử cái này phát đây như này.
Giả sử trong trường hợp này đúng không?
Thì thằng này không thể so sánh
được bởi vì đây là đây đang mảng với
chuỗi đúng không?
thằng này như này lú nhỉ.
kiểu gì thế anh? À không, anh tạo phím
tắt và anh dùng cái
hồi trước là anh có cái để mà kiểu chỗ
màn hình ở bên góc bên này thì hiển thị
ra bàn phím đang gõ có gì ấ anh cũng
chưa cài th quên mất đấy.
động chuyển string tôi lại nhớ lại quả
script mấy cái lú. Ok
không sao mình cứ từ từ đã.
rồi à
nó là cái an thôi. Anh nhớ là cái an để
mà tab táab qua các thứ thôi. Anh kiểu
đang thao tác kiểu nhanh quá anh cũng
không để ý.
bằng được. Đúng tôi tôi hiểu
à Ồ ok bằng bằng này thực ra nó liên
quan đến địa chỉ thôi đúng không? Không
phải là so sánh giá trị nữa.
array tra. Uầi có thế luôn à. Hay vậy.
Đâu xem à
đang học cơ bản nâng cao nữa. Buồn cười
quá chưa? Đây như này đúng không? Cái
này là đây
tu
cha ar ui đỉnh à. So sánh kiểu mẹ
thằng PP đọc đoạn này. What the
giờ tôi học Java tôi cảm thấy tôi buồn
cười quá c thế giới khác.
Tôi không biết là mấy ông từ Java sang
PP như nào. Tôi chắc chắn là từ PP sang
Java cho buồn cười
Tôi nhớ vụ pu này rồi.
lên Java. Hôm qua ông em cũng ngồi nói
là công ty em vẫn dùng Java 8 đấy. Đặc
biệt là ông em là bị ngân hàng mà. Xong
rồi kêu là còn Java mười mấy rồi nghe
kiểu
intern được chưa? Đưa world vào pool và
trả về reference lấy từ po.
Đợi đợi tí đợi tí giả sử không đọc phần
dưới. Đấy tôi zoom to lên. Không biết
mấy ông có
hay zoom cho tôi không? Chắc chắn có thể
là không. Nhưng đại khái tôi thường hay
zoom mọi thứ rất là to. Đấy. À đợi tí
except nó mất cái hiển thị đây nữa. Đấy.
Coi như không đọc thấy phần dưới nhá.
Không nhìn thấy phần dưới nhá.
Thì tôi tự hiểu đoạn này đã trước khi
xuống ví dụ.
À in term đưa chuỗi vào p tức là kiểu
là kiểu đầu tiên là tạo mới ngoài pu lúc
đầu là hello đúng không? Ok.
So với thêm một cái nữa.
như cũng
tạo mới mà nhỉ. Cũng có vào pool đâu
đúng không? Đây tôi nhớ là thế
Chắc là chỉ là tạo mới thôi. Chắc chắn
là kiểu gì nó cũng ngoài pu rồi. Cái này
nó hơi thừa đúng không?
Đấy, tôi vừa học xong tôi nhớ mà đừng
lừa. Đấy, in term đấy. Thêm chữ interm
là nhét nó lại vào pool này. Ok. Xong
rồi trả về reference tức là kiểu địa chỉ
con trỏ trỏ về địa chỉ đúng không? Đấy.
Rồi lấy ra từ pool
Nghĩa là nghĩa ở đây vừa nãy có ông nói
về cái hip đấy. Nó nhắc về cái hip mà
đúng không?
Đâu cái hip rồi
đấy. Bình thường là new là sẽ tạo trong
hip. Hip cũng là bộ nhớ. Nhưng mà hit nó
khác với pu đúng không?
Nếu thế thì rõ ràng là có. Đợi đợi tí
đợi tí nhá. Sẽ có hip này, po này. Xong
vừa nãy có ông còn nói stack này đúng
không?
P nó cứ hình dung là mặc định dùng cái
này thì nó sẽ vào pool đúng không? Cái
này bằng new string thì nó sẽ vào hit
đúng không? Nó sẽ không vào p nữa. P là
cái sân chơi chung đúng không? Đấy. Thế
stack này nữa là gì?
Ôi con P nằm trong híp nữa.
híp với stack thôi đúng không?
Ok. Hơi lú đấy nhưng mà thôi không sao
c sống mà.
Đấy.
hay sai nhá. Không, về sau tôi học mà
tôi mất gốc tôi lại bảo đổi tại qua
YouTube thì xếp chửi.
bình luận trên YouTube.
double check à kiểm tra chéo nhau nhá.
Tôi không biết kiến thức gì coi như là
tôi tôi chẳng lẽ tôi lại hỏi ai
chưa chưa chưa đến lúc quá tải thông tin
thế cứ bình tĩnh đã tôi không nhớ hết
đống kia đâu đấy
Gravity với Cloude thỉnh thoảng Gemini.
Ok rồi.
Tạo object mới này. Xong rồi đưa world
và pool bằng cách là dùng cái hàm
intern. Ok.
Kiểu Fer được vào
trả về. Trả về á.
Không báo lỗi mà đúng không? Chẳng qua ở
đây là thêm kiểu nó sẽ trả về cái địa
chỉ đúng không? Kiểu nhét mày vào cái ô
kiểu nhét mày vào cái sân bóng này đúng
không? trả về cái phiếu mày thích thì
mày có thể cầm cái phiếu này để gọi đến
thằng đấy. Đấy, kiểu kiểu thế đúng
không? Ok.
Trong trường hợp này sẽ bằng bằng được
này.
Tái sử dụng chuỗi trong p. Ok.
Uầy đoạn này lú thật. Kiểu nếu mà kiểu
không làm chuyên giả sử giả sử nhá. Tôi
PP sang đây code Java tôi không biết về
cái p cái hit cái stack mấy ông đang
nói. Đấy tôi chỉ cần biết là khai báo
chuỗi thôi. Tôi có thể new string này
hoặc là khai báo thẳng luôn như này đúng
không? Đấy tôi sẽ không biết tái sử dụng
lại cái pu hay các thứ thứ đúng không?
Đấy ui lúc đấy lú lúc ấy một là mình sẽ
bị lỗi khi mà code hai là mình sẽ không
biết tối ưu về bụn nhớ nhở.
Đúng kiểu chỉ code được thôi nhở. Tôi
nghĩ phải học chuyên sâu như này thì mới
tối ưu được những cái dương con bụn nhớ.
Ôi quá tải kiến thức luôn ý.
bên JavaScript cũng kiểu cộng chuỗi cộng
chuỗi trong buụt cười ấy. Trong PP thì
đương nhiên là không có cái khái niệm
cộng chuỗi như này mà phải có dấu riêng
cộng cộng trừ chúng ta chỉ làm với
chúng ta chỉ làm với số thôi. Cộng chuỗi
khó chịu thật.
nhớ mang máng ấy nhưng là nó còn liên
quan đến cả cộng được array mà đúng
không?
PP lại có cộng array nhá. Đúng rồi. Tôi
nhớ PP có vụ cộng array. Tức là sao? Bởi
vì tôi nhớ
cái này liên quan đến kiến thức mà tôi
từng học Java thời đấy nhá. Lâu rồi tôi
cứ hỏi lại mấy ông th chắc nhá. là kiểu
tôi nhớ là cái chuỗi này thực ra là
giống như vừa nãy khai báo cái tra tra
vừa nãy là bản chất là nó là cái mảng
mảng danh sách các ký tự đúng không? Đấy
thế nên là khi cộng như này ngang bằng
là array cộng với array đúng không? Được
mà đúng không? Thực ra cái này đang chỉ
array ba chữ cộng với array hai chữ mà
đúng không? Thì chắc là array cộng với
array chắc mại không được à.
đúng mà đúng không? Nghĩa là trong
trường hợp như thế này nhá. Giả sử chuỗi
này là có năm chữ đi đúng không? Giả sử
là S12 tại 0 như này sẽ bằng H được mà
đúng không? Không được à?
À cái này là string mất rồi. Nó không
còn array nhỉ.
còn chọc đến từng cái a kiểu cái index
của
mà tôi nhớ là có so sánh kiểu thế mà
chắc không phải thằng string này đúng
không?
Không sao, chắc là về sau học kể gì sẽ
đến đoạn đấy. Tôi sẽ tự vận lẽ ra sau.
Ok.
Tạ up mới tại run time.
13 với 12 là khác. Ồ bởi vì cái này là
sau đó nó mới cộng. Uầi lại lại thêm một
cái lú nữa.
khái niệm run time nữa nhỉ. Trong PP thì
nó sẽ không có. Nó sẽ so sánh hai thằng
bằng nhau luôn. À đây đây là khác địa
chỉ nhở. Đúng đúng đúng đúng đúng đúng.
Giá trị thì bằng nhau nhưng địa chỉ
khác. Ok. Đây là đúng rồi. Ở trong này
nó vẫn thường là liên quan đến cái khái
niệm về địa chỉ nữa.
đấy tôi có nhớ mang máng nên tôi không
sao tôi hỏi thế thôi. Hơi a hơi làm
phiền mấy ông tí.
Đ tôi về sau tôi sẽ
về sau tôi sẽ tự vỡ lẽ ra và lúc đấy tôi
sẽ à thế ra thế lúc đấy ông còn lú hơn
mẹ nói đến cái đoạn nào vậy
đây so sánh với PP ra script ui đợi mãi
sao những cái bên kia không có xem nào.
Đây nói chung là liên quan đến so sánh
cùng địa chỉ. Ok rồi.
À nãy giờ còn chưa chạy thử đoạn code
này. Tí chạy thử để mày in ra xem trông
như thế nào.
Đúng rồi. So sánh value không có string
poo hay cái gì cả. Đơn giản dễ dễ học
đấy. Đúng là làm quen với đô la còn ja
script. Ok so sánh ừ so sánh cả ba dấu
bằng luôn. Đây ba dấu bằng không phải
mỗi kiểu giá nó là kiểu giá trị với cả
giá trị
kiểu kiểu dữ liệu với giá trị luôn.
này không có ba dấu bằng nhỉ đúng không?
Nó sẽ so sánh kiểu là cùng địa chỉ
reference đúng không ạ? Đấy. Bract ok
luôn đã nhớ.
Visual bộ nhớ.
Đấy. Ui còn hiển thị bộ nhớ kiểu này.
Uầy.
Đây vừa nãy bạn kia có đề cập thự ạ. Nằm
trong híp đúng không? Nên là có pu đây
ab thì cả cái thằng biến này và biến này
đều trỏ đến hai. Ok.
Còn nếu mà hit ở ngoài pool thì thằng
object 1 này sẽ cho đến cái string này.
Object 2 chò string này với địa chỉ khác
nhau. Uầ thấy không? AI
không? Đấy là tôi nãy giờ tôi còn tôi
còn hỏi mấy ông ấy tôi mà nãy giờ giả sử
tôi học một mình tôi cứ thắc mắc gì tôi
lại hỏi ai ai trả lời cho tôi. Nó có thể
nó có thể đúng có thể sai không biết
được nhưng mà ý tôi là cá nhân hóa là
kiểu phục vụ cho mình cá nhân rất là tốt
đúng không?
Tóm tắt quan trọng uầy
cái này tôi nghĩ là mấy ông cũng thể
tham khảo học được ấy chứ nhỉ? Được ấy
chứ quá ổn sao? các cách tạo stream
đây gọi là literal.
Ok.
Tôi không biết là mấy ông có nhớ hết tất
cả cái từ khóa với định nghĩa không
nhưng mà tôi thấy là cũng nhiều phết đấy
nhỉ. Nhiều phết. PP nó không nhiều thế
này đâu.
Run time là lúc code chạy. Tine là lúc
biên dịch. Tine là run time là nó
gì nhở? Chắc là tôi sẽ phải biết cái đấy
sau.
Thì tôi tôi định hỏi cái nhưng chắc là
tôi sẽ khi đến cái đoạn đấy thì tôi sẽ
hỏi sau. So sánh địa chỉ bộ nhớ và so
sánh nội dung buồ. Ok.
Tại sao phải dùng của không biết string
được tạo bằng high new? Đúng. Ồ quá hợp
lý có thể dùng kết quả sai khi so sánh
string. Đúng an toàn 100% nó n giống như
kiểu hai dấu băng hay ba dấu băng đúng
không ạ?
chứ bình thường không đề cập nhớ. Đúng
tôi tôi hiểu
thì ý tôi là mấy cái này nó quá rộng và
cũng có nhiều lý thuyết mà đúng không?
nhiều lý thuyết đấy sẽ thậm chí là mình
nhớ nhiều quá mình cẩn thận bị nhầm ấy.
Đấy
nhưng cái này công nhận hay đấy nghĩa là
khi mà mình phải đến tôi nghĩ là may ý
bởi vì tôi đã đến cái ngưỡng mà kiểu giả
sử là tôi biết so sánh rồi. Giả sử tôi
làm PP nó cũng tương đối rồi. Khi mà tôi
sang đây tôi mới thấy kiểu so sánh được
tôi mới cảm thấy nó hay. Chứ nếu mà giả
sử tôi mới học Java là tôi nhìn ống này
h giống như hồi đầu tôi mới học Java
nhìn ống này tôi không nhớ lắm tôi không
ấn tượng lắm chỉ thấy nó khó kiểu nó bị
khó phức tạp hóa vấn đề lên ấy. Đấy
nhưng bây giờ khi mà mình đang từ PP
mình biết được là PP có những cái nhược
điểm gì rồi đúng không? Mình sang đây
mình biết à cái thằng này tại sao nó lại
phổ biến thế. Bởi vì nó tận nó đấy có
những cái nhỏ nhỏ như này nó đã
này tiết kiệm bộ nhớ tăng hiệu suất này.
Đấy. Ui
xịn quá xịn. Khi nào dùng intern fesser
tôi sẽ nhớ cái cái đoạn đấy
khi nhiều string từ bên ngoài đấy.
Database này, file API này.
giờ theo. Ổn không ạ?
Ờ
tôi xin trả lời câu này của bạn kia tí
đã nhá. Đầu tiên là
ờ khi mà các bạn hỏi kiểu một cái gì đó
ổn không đúng không ạ? Thì theo mình các
bạn nên phải xác định rõ đó là
à ví dụ giả sử trong trường hợp deop bạn
đang hỏi nhá là bạn hiểu khái niệm về
deop chưa? Đã. Đấy bạn phải nghiên cứu
cực kỳ kỹ về nó đã nhá.
định nghĩa của nó ấ chứ không phải nó sẽ
làm gì vân vân một phần đâu. Định nghĩa
nó bởi vì nhá định nghĩa của dep của
mình mình biết nhá
mình biết ở nhiều công ty nó khác nhau
cơ sự ngay công ty mình đã thấy khác
rồi. Ví dụ một cái điển hình công ty
mình ốp ở bên công ty mình thực ra lại
đang làm việc là quản lý mỗi hệ thống và
sếp mình còn bảo là đấy là công việc
giống như là chức vụ của system admin
chứ không phải một desop tức là chỉ quản
lý hệ thống thôi. Đấy còn depop như xếp
mình định nghĩa thì nó là nó lại liên
quan đến lịch sử của bên DEP một tí. À
cái này là mình nghe sếp nói và mình
nghe cũng hợp lý nhá. Mình chia sẻ các
bạn thôi chứ định nghĩa mỗi bên khác
nhau mình cũng tra rồi nên là mình không
hề nói là cái nào chuẩn nhá. Thì là hồi
đầu là anh em sẽ rõ ràng là một ông làm
back end, một ông làm fun end đúng không
ạ? Xong rồi khi mà ngồi dép ghép vào với
nhau để chạy một cái phần mềm thì tự
nhiên nó bị lỗi đủ thứ đúng không ạ? Và
còn phải đợi nhau nữa nên là sẽ sinh ra
khái niệm full stack. Tức là một ông làm
từ đầu đến cuối cả giao diện và cả phần
xử lý. Đấy để không ông nào chờ ông nào
đúng chưa ạ? Ok rồi xong rồi về sau
khi phát triển phần mềm đôi khi mình cần
tích hợp sang bên thứ ba nữa. Ví dụ giả
sử bây giờ mình tích hợp sang cổng thanh
toán, mình tích hợp sang cái bên ví dụ
là hồi trước mình làm trang tìm kiếm thì
mình tích hợp lên cả những cái pack
những cái thư viện về tìm kiếm đấy các
thứ thứ. Thì thay vì mình phải gọi sang
một à mình phải gọi một cái ông để ông
đấy ngồi cài cho mình cái phần mềm hay
là cài mình cái bên thứ ba đấy tự mình
cài luôn giống ông vuông sách là chẳng
cần phải đợi ai xếp giao việc cho mình.
Mình cứ thế mà cứ làm mọi thứ để mà nó
chạy được. Đấy thì cái từ dep off nó ra
đời. Tức là dep off là bản thất là nó là
full stack kết hợp với
có de nghĩa là de mà đúng không? Kết hợp
với ở đây. Off này tôi không nhớ từ viết
tắt nó là gì nhưng đại khái nó liên quan
đến về hệ thống ấy. Tức là chị ạ. Ông có
thể tự kiểu cài đặt môi trường, tự làm
mọi thứ để sao cho
kiểu chạy được một cái tính năng để làm
thử từ đầu đến cuối em không cần phải
nhờ bất kỳ ai cả. Ông tự làm được. Ví dụ
là thế nên là một cái khái niệm à
dep bây giờ cần phải học chính chỉ về
Amazon hay gì gì đó bởi vì kết nối sang
B3 thường là liên quan cloud liên quan
đến hạ tầng liên quan Amazon gì gì đấy
đây để mà có thể tích hợp sang bên đấy
thôi thì như mình vừa phân tích thì rõ
ràng là theo dep ổn không thì chắc chắn
là dep là cái kiểu ưu tiên của các công
ty bây giờ vì rõ ràng là thay vì tôi
tuyển một ông làm backend một ông mà fen
thậm chí một ông làm về hệ thống tuyển
một ông biết cả ba thì nó vẫn tốt để
giao việc cho nó là đủ đúng không? Đấy
nhưng mà
chính vì như thế thành ra công ty nó
cũng hơi a
bóc lột và nó hơi kiểu ờ yêu cầu hơi quá
cao. Và nếu mà bạn mới thì rõ ràng là
bạn phải học phải ba cái như mình vừa
nói đúng không ạ? phải học backend, fun
và một tí về bên các nền tảng thứ ba để
mà bạn biết tích hợp vào.
Đấy thì bây giờ chuẩn là bạn nếu mà như
luồng bạn mình vừa nói
thì bạn phải học
back end trước xong rồi fun gì gì đó
trước các thứ đúng không ạ?
Đấy.
xong hai ông có có mâu thuẫn xung đột
với nhau. Thành ra là cuối cùng ghép vào
nó không chạy.
đúng không ạ? Đấy, thế nào mình không
làm bên, mình cũng không hướng đến bên
từ trước đến nay nên là mình cũng không
kiểu trên sâu tìm hiểu gì đấy. Mình chỉ
biết về khái niệm lý thuyết, kiểu lịch
sử hình thành với kiểu tại sao có từ đấy
thôi. Còn yêu cầu nó bây giờ là gì hay
là bây giờ nó đã thay đổi như nào rồi
thì mình chịu.
Mình lại thường mình tính của mình
thường hay kiểu như thế là mình muốn đi
về cái cốt lõi. Ấ, hiểu không? Mấy ông
đôi khi phải đơn giản hóa. Cái này tôi
học giữ cũng từ xếp luôn là phải đơn
giản hóa mọi cái
đi lại về cái nguồn gốc cốt lõi để ông
hiểu được là cái bản chất của nó lúc đầu
là gì. Và thậm chí là bây giờ ông khi mà
ông nhìn lại ông sẽ thấy nó biến tướng
như nào chẳng hạn. Nghĩa là nó sẽ khác
như nào bởi vì đôi khi là công việc nó
sẽ chỉ cần giải quyết bài toán đơn giản
kiểu kia thôi. Nhưng mà tại do kiểu tam
sao đất bản hay vân vân gì đó nên thành
ra nó bị hỗn độn như bây giờ. Nó làm khó
hiểu như bây giờ. Đấy thì ông quay lại
cái kiểu cái gốc dễ của nó ấy thì ông
giải quyết được nó là đôi khi là toàn bộ
những cái kia lại mượn. Ông ông hiểu ý
không? Đây
đây. Ông kia vừa khuyên một cái thêm một
cái hay nữa kìa. Tôi không học bên đấy
nên là tôi không rõ đâu.
So với PP so sánh value trực tiếp. Đúng
rồi. String
đúng rồi. String của Java script còn
muôn trùng nữa. Nếu chỉ hai dấu bằng rất
rất có lỗi.
Th PP cũng có mà PP có khái niệm là tôi
hồi trước tôi vẫn nhớ quả là truyền lên
là nun xong rồi PP
PP lại kiểu cố convert nó lại thành
string thành string nun. Rồi string nun
nên thành ra là không biết string nun
rồi nó lại kiểu nó là một cái giá trị
đúng không? Nó không còn là hiểu không
có giá trị nữa đúng không? Đấy
buồn cười lắm
dạng là get ý thì ông truyền lên n thì
đương nhiên nó chẳng convert lại thành
string đúng không?
chuẩn là nun thì không nên truyền lên.
Đấy theo tôi như thế hoặc như là nếu mà
thấy thì ông phải biến thành dạng method
không phải method get đúng không?
làm trên Hà Nội một thời gian rồi về
quê.
Đấy tôi đang dịch cái câu của bạn hỏi là
như thế đúng không ạ? Nhưng mà tester so
với DEP là như nào nhỉ? là ý bạn là về
mọi thứ đúng không? Kiểu nếu mà hỏi câu
rộng thấy là mọi thứ đúng không? Là kiểu
đái ngộ này hay là cả về mức độ khó hay
vân vân đúng không? Câu trả lời đều là
dead. Vẫn có thiên hướng là mọi thứ đều
hơn tester về kiểu khó hay là đãi ngộ
mọi thứ hơn thì đương nhiên là khó hơn
đương nhiên đãi ngộ tốt hơn đúng không
ạ?
Nhưng mà ờ nhưng mà bạn Hoa Sinh nè thì
chắc là nữ à thường à mọi người vẫn
khuyên là bạn nữ thì một là tetơ hai là
ba hoặc là thậm chí DA nhưng mà theo
mình thì
bạn cứ phải thử đã đúng không? Mình
không khuyên các bạn là theo được một
cái gì đó luôn. Các bạn thử đã xong rồi
các bạn sẽ kiểu thử ở đây là phải học
giống như kiểu mình ấy là 100 ngày là 3
tháng các bạn phải học tầm như thế không
nên thì mới một là 100 ngày này, hai là
3 tháng này, thậm chí là 1000 giờ này
các bạn mới biết được thực sự các bạn
hợp cái gì. Nếu mà bạn các bạn mà dễ
nản, dễ bỏ cuộc trước thời gian đấy thì
theo mình là mọi nghề mọi nghề đều sẽ
khó theo. Đặc biệt là ngành IT này thì
càng khó.
100 ngày thực ra nó nhanh lắm đấy. Hôm
nay ngày một nhá ông mấy ông sẽ thấy là
100 ngày vèo vo
thì mình mới kiểu gọi như là kiếm được
việc mà mình kiếm được việc mà người
khác gọi là bây giờ đang tranh đua nhau
việc mà đúng không ạ?
phải biết code thực ra tùy test ở tùy từ
công ty ví dụ công ty tôi thực ra công
ty tôi ra không tester không cần biết
code lắm đấy tester chỉ cần bị đúng
nghĩa là test giao diện với dùng pman
hay mọi thứ nhưng mà vẫn phải nên có một
cái gì đó lộ trình mà đúng không ạ từng
cuối có thể là bạn không giỏi ở mặt code
nhưng mà bạn Biết
lộ trình kiểu biết ưu và nhược ấy, biết
được mình còn thiếu cái gì chẳng hạn ấy
đúng không? Ví dụ hôm nay tôi hỏi bạn
sinh viên của tôi chẳng hạn, sinh viên
bạn ấy học ở trên trường bị dàn trải
quá, bạn không hề biết ưu vào nhược của
bản thân để nói. Bạn ấy đang nghĩ là bạn
đang làm tốt thôi. Tôi cũng không biết
thực sự bạn đang làm tốt cái gì đấy.
Chẳng hạn thế không biết bạn ấy đang
nghe không? Bạn đang nghe chắc tế tôi
chết mất. Nhưng mà ý tôi như thế nghĩa
ông phải thực sự ông phải học từ đầu đến
cuối một cái gì đó gốc gáp, một cái
chuẩn chỉ để ông thực sự ông biết được
là ông đang thiếu cái gì. Ví dụ giả sử
tôi học PP
nhưng tôi biết được là tôi thiếu bên
mảng về chặt chẽ của bên Java để tôi
sang học này như này chẳng hạn. Đấy khi
mà mình biết được mình có ưu nhược là
gì, mình đang thiếu cái gì đó như này
thì mình mới dễ học. Còn nếu mà ông còn
học theo kiểu học vẹt hay học kiểu ngắt
quãng hay học tua hay vân vân vân gì đó
không chuẩn chỉ
ông sẽ không hề biết được ông đang thiếu
cái gì và ông đi phỏng vấn
một là người ta hỏi đến hai đi làm kiểu
gì cũng gặp thì sẽ chết không biết gì cả
đúng không ạ
test
đã từng học qua code nhưng bạn ấy cảm
thấy là không theo được code thì bạn vẫn
có thể là kiểu học qua SQL mình có dạy
SQL cơ bản để bạn có thể tham khảo hoặc
là tùy trên mạng có nhiều mà đấy qu bởi
vì nếu mà tester mà chỉ thuần về làm
test giao diện mà không không dùng AI để
mà có thể dùng AI sinh ra code nhá giả
sử như bạn không động tí về AI này không
động tí về code này mà không dùng hay là
không dùng SQL
thì
tự nhiên hạn chế bản thân thôi đúng
không ạ? Đấy bạn nên kiểu không về code
nhưng mà phải về cái khác một tí các thứ
các thứ đúng không ạ? Thì nó sẽ ổn hơn.
Bây giờ ông ngày nào cũng vào bình luận
về
kiểu như là không thể nói về khoe về bản
thân được nhưng mà
ừ nhưng là ông phải có một bình luận.
Ngày nào ông bình luận có một điểm nhấn
ở đó thì sẽ dễ.
thích cũng được. Quan trọng là đấy giống
như là tôi bây giờ tôi đang không hiểu
thì tôi nhờ ai học cùng cũng hầm một
cách mà. Thầy đang dậu dậy ở đâu thế?
Tôi đang ngồi nhà không ạ?
Học một mình cũng nả là anh có anh live
học cho có động lực. Cảm ơn. Tôi cũng
thế. Đấy do tôi live đây hợp một mình có
vẻ hơi buồn không có kiểu thúc đẩy cùng
mấy ông hãy coi cái này giống như b cá
để mấy ông ngồi nghe để du ngủ hoặc là
ngồi làm việc cũng được.
Bạn sinh ơi nếu học test thì nên học
thêm cả tiếng Nhật nhữ nữa sau có thể dễ
sang tester cộng học hành với khách là
hợp lý. Ô ông kia khuyên cũng hay bởi vì
đấy khuyên thấy khá là kiểu thực tiễn
bởi vì bây giờ đúng rồi
bên a
bên Nhật bây giờ cũng đang tuyển bên
mình này. Tiếng tiếng Nhật bây giờ đúng
là tuyển nó sẽ tôi cảm thấy nó sẽ dễ hơn
tiếng Anh bây giờ. Tiếng Anh đấy là theo
tôi
xung quanh
ở trên công ty tôi bây giờ vẫn đang ngon
lành nhưng mà tôi gần đây tôi mua hẳn
cái cũng là
mới gần nhất ông ạ. Đấy, kiểu cũng đúng
kiểu đợt
kiểu đợt đấy là đợt đ được thưởng hay gì
đó. Tôi nhớ là tôi cũng đầu tư hẳn một
cái
nó khác nhau có khác nhưng mà nó không
gọi như là bây giờ giả sử bây giờ nó
đang nhanh rồi nên thành ra là kiểu khi
mà nó nâng lên thì nó vẫn chỉ là nhanh
thôi. Đấy
code luôn P project đi anh. Có chứ có
chứ. Tôi sẽ học xong Java tôi sẽ code
pet project mấy ông có thể ngồi xem tham
khảo cùng. Hồi trước
ủ mấy cái làm pet project đang nửa chừng
rồi. Nhiều lắm.
Tiếp tục học đi anh. Không cái này thôi.
Đấy mấy ông cũng ham học chúng tôi rồi
đúng không? Ừ một buổi sẽ chỉ học tầm
này thôi.
Cái này hãy nên nhớ là mình học toàn bộ
cái đống này trong 5 ngày đầu. Bây giờ
tôi đã học được buổi thứ hai rồi đúng
không ạ? Tí để đánh số vào.
anh. Ồi ý tưởng đúng là từ trước hay tôi
nhiều kiểu nhiều kinh khủng. Hồi trước
là toàn có phải nhờ ông emy kia ngồi cốt
cùng hoặc ngồi làm giao diện cho nhưng
mà tôi giờ đã có ai ch nhưng mà bây giờ
vấn đề đấy là mình gọi như là mình không
có thời gian thật nhiều lúc và cầu.
Bây giờ cũng có tình yêu tình báo cũng a
à đấy ngồi học hay là thậm chí là gần
đây còn sẽ phải ngồi quan tâm sức khỏe
vân vân nữa. Đấy nhiều do lắm vẽ ra
nhiều lý do lắm. Có khi là chỉ mệt quá
muốn nằm thôi. Nhưng mà rõ ràng tôi có
nhiều ý tưởng thật.
Nhưng mà bây giờ tôi để lộ ý tưởng cho
mấy ông thì
tôi sẽ không lộ ý tưởng tôi sẽ nói mấy
ông đó là nó theo nhu cầu mấy ông thôi.
Vì rõ ràng là nhu cầu của tôi rất nhiều.
Chắc là tôi dùng nhiều phần mềm nữa chứ
tôi cảm thấy có cái phần mềm gì cân cấn.
Ấy ví dụ rõ ràng là có một cái phần mềm
trên mạng tôi dùng rồi cảm thấy không
hài lòng với nó. Tôi thích code hẳn một
cái nữa. Code để có thêm một cái tính
năng A, một tính năng B nữa. Chẳng hạn
thế được
tí AI không anh? P project tôi định làm
thực ra nó cũng chẳng cần liên quan đến
AI cả vì rõ ràng gọi đến AI nữa đôi khi
tốn phí thì tôi cảm thấy là tôi không ý
định tôi không gọi là nói chung là tôi
bỏ qua cái thời kỳ mà kiểu tham về công
nghệ rồi hồi trước thì kiểu ngượn non
hào đá thì kiểu sẽ tham mà kiểu giờ mình
phải làm ra một cái phần mềm rất là xịn
có rất nhiều tính năng vip đấy xong rồi
công nghệ mới nhất hay vân vân vân gìấy
công việc không thử ra mình làm độ lâu
đặc biệt công Công ty tôi là product mà
đây công ty tôi nói thẳng bây giờ còn
đang nhiều lúc đang không có khách thì
không quan tâm công nghệ ông đang dùng
xịn như nào đâu không ạ quan tâm về việc
kiểu nó đem lại thực sự giá trị người
dùng người dùng cần hay không không quan
tâm về công nghệ đâu không quan tâm
khách đâu quan tâm ông đang dùng công
nghệ gì hay kiểu xịn như thế nào không
khách khách có biết đâu khách quan tâm
đâu đúng không đấy
những cái dự án cá nhân ý đấy. Những dự
án cá nhân bé bé thì sẽ gọi là bé phách
ông mà nửa đêm ông nghe thì ông sẽ không
thấy chiu lắm đâu.
thôi.
To gọi startup à? Cũng được. Nếu mà
startup tự thân, nếu mà không tốn tiền
nào thì vẫn có thể là PJ cũng được tùy
tù cái gọi.
Ok, hôm nay đã xong. Mấy cái này tôi vẫn
sẽ đẩy lên để mấy ông tham khảo nhá. Mấy
ông cứ sẵn sàng mạnh dạn ui cái gì đấy
giố nhiều này.
Person cái gì đấy lừa rồi
đã chạy cái gì đâu. Có person này
bình tĩnh bình tĩnh đợi tí. Sợ có person
nào đây này.
cái linh tinh này đã.
dùng hẳn thanh kinh đến giờ dùng thẳng
thẳng thh kinh rồi.
Sửa lại
cho tôi
cái project này.
Tôi muốn
mỗi thư mục
đã diện cho mút buổi,
m ngày chứ không phải
lắp lại
13 này. 1 năm gì đó.
nói thế vui mà
ghi rõ à
số thứ tự
ngày trong file này
cho tôi
rồi mấy ông ạ nói khăn rọng
nói liên tục
Em không dễ ngủ lắm. Em chuẩn bị tốt
nghiệp ạ. Xin muốn xin anh vài lời
khuyên.
Ok. Em cứ hỏi đi. Em a tốt nghiệp chắc
là khóa công nguyện công tin thôi nhỉ?
Đúng không? Ừ.
thì hơi khó khuyên. Chắc anh chỉ khuyên
được khoản là viết cách cách CV xong rồi
phỏng vấn hay gì gì đó. Ví dụ cách CV
thì anh vẫn thường ha khuyên đó là nó
phỏng vấn hay CV. Nói chung thì nó vẫn
tôi từng nói từ mấy cái video hồi trước
rồi. Đó là giống như việc ông đi tn gái
vậy. Ông không thể dùng một bài cho tất
cả. Tức là sao? Nghĩa là phải xẽ lên xem
tìm hiểu qua công ty đấy là nó đang có
nhu cầu gì đã và mình sẽ sửa CV sao cho
phù hợp với cái nhu cầu đấy sẽ tránh cái
việc là ông áp dụng một bài để tất cả
đúng không ạ? Đấy nó như thế thôi. Kiểu
ừ ông không thể kiểu đăng một cái status
ta kiểu ai yêu tôi không saong rồi sẽ có
rất nhiều người vô gặp mào đúng không ạ?
Giống như là ông việc ông gửi C C CV
cũng thế. Ông không thể gửi một cái CV
rất là chung chung xong gửi cho tất cả
mọi người được à tất cả công ty được
đấy. Phải phải sửa lại theo từng công
ty. Ông có thể dùng AI để mà sửa. Thậm
chí là dùng AI để góp ý. Hôm trước tôi
dùng AI để thử ném đá ra CP của tôi
chẳng hạn. Đấy,
đúng rồi. Sựa dựa vào JD hiển nhiên luôn
làm chi là không phải GD là đủ. Ông phải
thực sự là ông phải lên trang web của
công ty tìm hiểu. Nếu mà lý tưởng hơn là
ông phải nhắn tin với cả
bên kiểu nhân viên bên đấy để mà thực sự
hỏi xem là công ty có vấn đề gì, có
những cái đang đang làm dự án gì vân
vân. Nói chung là tìm hiểu thôi nó n là
giống như vừa rồi tôi nói con gái kiểu à
có bạn nữ ở đây nhỉ thôi tám nửa kia đi
thì mấy ông cũng phải đi tìm hiểu qua
bạn bè của người ta có thể thế rất nhiều
cách đúng không tìm hiểu qua bởi vì hãy
nên nhớ là đây là không tìm việc ở đây
nó giống tìm yêu ra mình tìm những cái
phù hợp với mình nhá chứ không phải là
mình cứ chọn bừa đấy không thể yêu bừa
chọn bừa được đúng không ạ thì tìm người
phù hợp tức là sao nghĩa là ông tìm hiểu
qua xem công ty phù hợp với ông không?
Ông có đủ điều kiện để làm công ty đấy
không? Công ty nó quá chán này hay là
công ty nó quá xa vân vân rất nhiều cái
đúng không?
Đương nhiên là ông sẽ nghĩ là ông mới ra
trường thì ai
gọi là đâm đầu yêu không thế nào cũng
được bất chấp để lấy kinh nghiệm cũng
được cũng là một cách nhưng mà có rất
nhiều người làm như thế nên là thành ra
là
nó lại phù hợp những công ty nó hơi tảm
nham một tí đấy còn công ty mà nó khá
chuẩn chuyên nghiệp giống như là con
người ta cũng là con người tử tế đúng
không
cách của anh virus
Không biết đang hiểu nó cái gì nhưng mà
đấy con người ta là con nhà tử tế thì
mình sẽ phải rất là chuẩn chi để phù hợp
đấy đúng không? Đấ mình phải chuẩn bị
trước đấy nhiều mà.
Nói chung là thực ra tôi bây giờ tôi bởi
vì tôi cũng đang chưa hẳn là
hôm trước mới là lần thứ hai trong đời
tôi đi phỏng vấn.
À những lần trước có phỏng vấn nhá toàn
là người quen giới thiệu nên gần như nó
sẽ khác.
Không biết rồi tôi lần trước tôi đã kể
tâm sự mấy ông về phỏng vấn lần đầu của
tôi chưa? Nhưng là lần đầu phỏng vấn của
tôi thì tôi cũng ngồi chém ba hoa, không
phải chém gió ba hoa nữa. Nhưng mà đại
khái là tôi cũng dẫn dắt câu chuyện đấy.
Tôi cảm thấy tôi vẫn tự tin là tôi đã
làm chủ được cái cuộc phóng vấn đấy. Đó
là thay vì người ta hỏi mình kiểu cứ
người ta hỏi rồi mình trả lời ấ thì mình
sẽ mình chủ động cho câu chuyện luôn là
mình ngồi nói những cái ưu của mình
luôn. Giống như kiểu đi hẹn hò là mình
sẽ tránh cái việc là
buổi phỏng vấn là kiểu cứ để hỏi và trả
lời đúng không? Mình dẫn dắt mình kể một
câu chuyện đúng không? Mình kể câu
chuyện của mình, một cái kinh nghiệm của
mình để cho người ta biết được là à cái
góc nhìn của mình là như nào, khi mình
gặp vấn đề mình sẽ xử lý như nào đấy
đúng không? Đấy, họ sẽ biết qua về con
người và cách nói chuyện mình nữa. Nó sẽ
kiểu mở hơn ấy, thay vì chỉ dừng lại
trong mỗi mấy cái câu hỏi có sẵn đúng
không? Đấy và à buổi gần nhất đấy nhưng
mà buổi hôm đấy là tôi đi phỏng vấn kia
không có quay tại thì cái quay kia quay
gần nhất tôi đăng thì nó sẽ là
làm online ở nhà này. Hình như hôm nãy
mặc bộ này phả không biết rồi đấy thì
mấy ông có thể xem cái buổi phỏng vấn
gần nhất tôi đăng thì ông sẽ thấy cách
tôi tự tin vào cái video đấy trừ cái
điểm mà tôi phát âm có thể tiếng Anh nó
không hay thôi.
Đấy
mà hôm nay tôi có nghĩ rồi đấy. Đó là
update cái bộ cái vụ tuyển dụng trong PP
trong Discord.
Thực ra có một sự thật đó là tôi định để
trong đấy là rất nhiều ngôn ngữ không
phải mỗi PP nhưng mà thằng tag của thằng
Discord nó giới hạn đúng không ạ? Nên
thành ra tôi mới phải kiểu thôi thì để
mỗi PP trong đấy chứ thật ra tôi định để
nhiều ngôn ngữ khác nữa được rồi. Bao
nhiêu để vào đây cũng được mà nhưng mà
không nó hình như nó giới hạn 15 hay 20
v thôi nên tôi mới phải thôi thì đà nào
mình dạy mỗi PP với ra Ja script hay gì
gì đó nên là mình để cái phần tuyển dụng
nó chỉ có mấy ngôn ngữ như thế
ơ có để Hồ Chí Minh mà nhỉ
lửa. Đợi tí tôi mở Discord ở trên đây
xem đã không có Hồ Chí Minh ấy nhỉ?
À ý mà có mấy cái chop á. Mấy cái chó
thì
tôi không thấy bên nào liên lạc với tôi
cả nên thành nó thế. Nghĩa là khi mà có
bên nào liên lạc với tôi thì tôi mới
đẩy lên đấy thôi. B cũng lâu lắm rồi.
Xem có Hồ Chí Minh mà có tác Hồ Chí Minh
chẳng qua là không có chó. Hồ Chí Minh
là không lên thôi.
Không không ưu tiên gì đâu. Có chob nào
thì đẩy lên đấy. Tại người quen tôi chắc
là không phải người quen. Tôi quen khá
nhiều kiểu
ừ gần như là vào nhiều nơi. Nhưng mà ý
tôi là người biết tôi dậy hay là các thứ
vân vân thì nó chủ yếu thì
trong tầm mà quan hệ mà kiểu hay gặp nên
thành ra là kiểu người ta sẽ gửi tôi vì
job ở Hà Nội nhiều nhất.
dạy on và tôi có sinh viên tôi ở các
tỉnh khác đâu đúng không? Không ai biết
điều đấy cả.
hẳn một cái row là row HR ở trong cái
server Discord đấy rồi. Mấy ông phải là
người kêu gọi HR vào trong đấy để ph
đăng tin tuyển dụng. Đấy kiểu như thế.
Tôi hồi đấy là tôi đã mời hai ba bạn HR
vào rồi đấy.
chưa dừng 8 ba.
tôi quen toàn nam nhưng mà tôi nhớ là
hình như có có nữ nhưng mà tôi cũng chưa
từng đ ba. Gần đây nhá. Tôi quen
đúng có đúng một bạn gần gần đây kiểu
như nào nhỉ.
Bây giờ khoe ra trên này cho anh em ném
đá.
Nhưng đại khái anh em mà theo dõi tôi
biết được là tôi đang có người yêu thì ừ
bạn hiện tại của tôi là là
cũng là de nghĩa là dân trong ngành đúng
không ạ? Nhưng mà ý tôi là từ trước nay
bạn đấy là người đầu tiên.
ở trong ngành chứ bình thường từ trước
nay tôi không quen con gái ở trong
ngành.
Quen thì đương nhiên là kiểu sinh viên
hay bạn bè thì có nhưng mà thể chưa tả
gà con gái trong ảnh.
Clip phỏng vấn đang ở đâu thế nhỉ? Ơ
trên kênh này này nhưng mà ở trong cái
video ấy chứ không phải là trong
thường mọi người sẽ có thể bấm vào
playlist hoặc là bấm vào cái gì à phát
trực tiếp gì đó. Còn đây là video ấy.
fake
kinh nghiệm không? Đấy, giống như bạn
kia chia sẻ là bảy phần thực, ba phần
nào thì anh nghĩ là
thựt là chẳng cần phải fake đâu. Rõ ràng
giống như nãy giờ mình đang đề cập là
tạo ra một cái một cái dự án cá nhân.
Em có thể ghi trong đấy, đúng là là em
ghi trong đấy những cái ngôn từ ngầu có
thể dùng AI để tạo ra nhưng nó vẫn là dự
án thực tế em đã làm thì vẫn được chẳng
có không cần. Nghĩa là toàn bộ những cái
trên vi đối với anh nhá. Toàn bộ những
cái trên CP mình đều viết là nó có thực
tế. Chẳng qua nó bị phòng đại theo kiểu
là theo kiểu là em làm em làm em làm năm
đi nhưng em khoe là 10 cũng được còn hơn
là em không làm rồi em khoe em có làm nó
khác hoàn toàn. Em hiểu ý ý anh không?
Nghĩa là em có thể dùng phóng đại không
sao cả. CV được phép phóng đại nhưng CV
không được phép nói láo xuyên tạc, nói
sai sự thật.
Đấy, trong trường hợp đối với anh sai
trường hợp là không làm đấy. Còn việc mà
em làm nhưng mà đấy đối với em đấy thành
công em khi vĩ đại rồi cũng được chơi
kiểu cùn kiểu thế kiểu em khoe ông si
phi em sản phẩm dự án này em rất là
thành công rất xịn chẳng qua đối với mọi
người thì sản phẩm đấy kiểu đểu. Nhưng
mà em mới ra trường em cảm thấy thế là
xịn rồi có sao đâu đúng không? người ta
không ai đánh giá ai cũng biết thừa việc
em phải ra trường thì kinh nghiệm em đến
đâu nên là không sao việc là trong CV em
bảo là nó rất là xịn đấy nhưng mà trong
CV của em tự nhiên em được kê là em đã
dùng giống như là trên sá tanh của nó áp
dụng blockchain áp dụng AI áp dụng kiểu
n thứ rồi đã làm tỷ tính năng trong đấy
kiểu thứ ra không phải thì lúc đấy là
đấy là bffet chem to quá đúng không hỏi
hai câu cái là tắt rồi thì không nên.
Lúc phỏng vấn nên thể hiện thái độ như
nào? Anh họ hỏi mình một mình nên trả
lời 230 hay trả lời theo chính họ hỏi
thôi. Thực ra nó là liên quan đến giống
như vừa nãy mình đề cập là mình nói
nhiều và mình chỉ cảm thấy mình dỡ dắt
được câu chuyện thì mình sẽ kể một câu
chuyện ra. Bởi vì một phần là câu chuyện
này không nên lặc đề nhá. Câu chuyện này
nó vẫn nên đúng đề và nó dựa theo kinh
nghiệm của mình. Còn nếu mà bạn đang
chưa có kinh nghiệm gì lắm thì bạn có
thể trả lời thành hai thì thôi là hợp
lý. Đừng có nên trả lời dài quá. Và và
hãy nên xem thời gian của họ với mình
hay xem biểu cảm của họ nữa. Cái này
liên quan kỹ năng mềm mà anh em IT được
là kém kỹ năng mềm n hơi khó để mà
khuyên.
không đánh đồng đâu nhưng mà mấy ông
hiểu mà đấy thì
tôi thế nghĩa là nếu giả sử mà họ tự
nhiên cảm thấy có gì đó là kiểu khc lại
kiểu họ thấy là không hài lòng mình
không thích mình lắm nữa thì mình biết
được phần nào là buổi phỏng vấn đây
không còn thành công nữa thì mình sẽ
trả lời. vẫn trả lời, vẫn mọi thứ vẫn
chuyên nghiệp nhá để vẫn giữ hình ảnh
cho chính mình đấy. Nhưng không nên quá
là dòng đấy. Thế thôi.
Đây có cái linkit hub kia kìa. Chính cái
gai này đấy. Ơ xong rồi này. Nó sửa xong
rồi này. Để tô xem nhá. Ok
đây một đây 2, đây 3. Ừ trong có vẻ rõ
ràng hơn rồi. Dù tôi không thích cái từ
đây này lắm thì thôi cũng được. Ok ok
ok. Tạm thời đã. Tôi tôi bây giờ tôi
chuẩn bị nghỉ rồi nên là tôi không có
thể review được cái đoạn này.
Nhưng mấy ông có thể
đẩy cái này lên để à mấy ông có thể
review hộ tôi nhá. Tôi sẽ sửa cái này là
ờ update
đây 1 năm kiểu như này đấy. Có gì mấy
ông xem lại rồi đây link hub đây. Không
biết mấy ông nào for hay đánh sao gì
chưa chưa ông nào cả. [tiếng cười]
Đây anh sẽ đánh sao. Ok rồi.
Ok. Xin chào mấy ông nhá. Còn thắc mắc.
Hả? Không ai gõ đâu. À có tiếng nước
chảy thôi. Không không không ai gõ đâu.
À
xin chào mấy ông. Hẹn mấy ông ngày mai.